all right I have some new tour dates to
announce uh we've just added a third
show in Milwaukee on September 9th at
the Riverside Theater tickets for that
are on sale now I'll also be in Oakland
California Akron Ohio Washington D.C Las
Vegas Nevada
um some of those have new shows those
are all at theovan.com
t-o-u-r and thank you so much for your
support new merch for you merch heads
out there we've got some new shorts
that's right the Rat Life shorts and
blue salmon and sand
we've also got the new tie-dye be good
to yourself teas in aqua creamsicle and
indigo
get that in more only at
theovinstore.com today's guest is a uh a
doctor of death baby he's at corner
and he's at death man
he sits right there on a doorstep of the
devil and when the buzzer Rings he
answers it
uh he's based out of Lafayette Louisiana
and um they got it all going down there
all type of death happening and he's
going to tell us more about it
I'm grateful for his time today he's 18
years in the profession today's guest is
Mr Toby savoir
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sitting here with a corner today Mr
Toby sabwa
and you are a corner I am actually
um a death investigator for the
coroner's office the coroner is somewhat
of a political position uh involves
being a doctor so we have a doctor
that's a coroner over or parish and then
the majority of the works done by death
investigators like myself okay now in
Louisiana they know you as the coroner
just you know it's too hard to to break
down medical death investigator versus
coroner or coroner's office oh it's too
hard to break down a good oyster
dressing recipe over there for somebody
that's right you know what I'm saying
you put too much information on somebody
in Louisiana they're going to start
punching that's right especially at a
time of death yeah they're not they're
not registering all that so we go with
coroner's office but we are legally
death investigators okay so when does
someone call a corner and and what is a
corner death investigator I'm going to
call it a corner for the episode that's
fine okay what is a coroner so a coroner
is um an elected position
but
what we do is we go out when someone
dies or we're called every time someone
dies that lives within our Parish okay
or County or county in Louisiana it's
parishes
um so we will we're called if it's a
natural case or if it's a homicide
suicide of any of the manners of death
um there's different rules for people
that may not be from Louisiana or from
or city and state
um if it's a natural cause it would go
back to that state of residence but
anytime it's an accident or just your
general natural death it comes to us
okay we have to pick up the phone and
decide you know is this natural causes
or is there Foul Play we work closely
with police okay so the police give you
a call that's right we'll get a call
from the Sheriff's Office the local city
police
hospitals nursing homes and they say
Toby we got a
yeah we have a case we have a we have a
so in healthcare we say patience okay in
the coroner's office it's subject so we
have a subject here who's uh an 86 year
old laying in bed okay and so then I
know what questions to ask and how to
pick the case apart and do you guys
physically go to the scene we do um okay
not all scenes I mean if it's an 80 year
old who's on hypertension medicine and
blood pressure medicine heart medication
um that's a gimme yeah that you know has
a really really uh history of medical
history we don't necessarily have to go
out for those the police are there to
call Foul Play right but if they're
laying in bed and they were found by
their spouse you know it's normally a
natural case if they see something that
may look suspicious then we'll go out
all right but for the majority of the
naturals we don't we we can release
those by phone and direct them to a
funeral home not even a zoom you don't
even have to do Zoom or nothing nothing
no we just we just take the call get the
information we still investigate the
death but we don't have to go out for
everyone okay so when you do go out do
you take like a tool kit with you or
what do you guys is there like
what do you bring with you how do you
approach a scene like if it's a sure a
death yeah so a subject so we have a bag
of gear that we use now in Louisiana
we're a poor State and a poor Parish
when I started they gave me a can often
a badge really said tell us when they
did no teasing but but
basically basically um we go out so we
we have sir we have tools that we use on
scene you know we need we need a
flashlight to see around sometimes
um the biggest thing that we do on scene
after investigating the scene which goes
into a lot of things we'll do toxicology
we'll draw blood
um if the person suspects suspected
overdose or overdose might be a
possibility and most of the overdoses by
the way are accidental overdoses people
hear OD and they think intentional but
so if we think drugs were involved we'll
bring a spinal needle or just a regular
syringe we can we can draw blood out of
the heart which is like a Pulp Fiction
scene the movie with the long spinal
needle y'all go right in we go right in
the heart there's no pulse so getting
blood out of veins when they're deceased
is is not a thing that we can do so we
take blood from the heart or we can go
in through the side of the eye and
that's called vitriol fluid and how much
is in the eye so we get about you know
four CC's out of the eye it's not always
uh some have more than others really but
we'll go in we'll tap in through the
side of the eye oh you're not into the
eyeball yeah I'm into the eyeball so I
take a two or three inch long needle and
I go in at a horizontal angle just to
puncture it and then I aspirate the
fluid out of there that's in the eye
that's in the eye yeah so that's
toxicology and when you're getting it
out the eyeball
um there's less of a chance that it
could clot up because we send these uh
specimens to uh forensic toxicology Labs
so when you're going through the heart
and the lungs sometimes it can have
blood clots in it and other things and
they may not be able to perform the test
99.9 of them with blood are fine but it
is nice having that and then the heart's
not always easy to find whether you know
it could be a car accident they could
have some major crushing going on in the
chest it could be a gunshot wound where
there's no blood left in the heart that
we can get oh wow so the eye is a second
option and then if that doesn't work we
can actually put a slit and the belly
and pull out a piece of liver and send
part of their liver off to a lab to be
analyzed so we we have a syringe with
several different sized needles
um and tools to use if we have to cut
into them to grab liver to send off and
so that's all for taking toxicology
that's right okay and what death
determine toxicot like which so you said
if it seems like a natural death you
guys can almost do it over the phone
right it's not if it's a different type
of death where there could have been a
homicide or an accident then you want to
show up and do toxicology correct we and
we do more than toxicology we're
investigating the scene everything
around it the home oh I mean we have to
we look at everything not only the body
but the surroundings a lot of times
that'll paint a picture of of what's
going on with that individual case
um for instance I had a case where you
know the the deputy was new
um he thought it was suspicious because
the 80 year old wife woke up and noticed
her spouse was cold and the timeline on
on that on that case the the deputy said
he's really cold and she's just finding
him well that's natural you know you're
sleeping you may not notice your
significant other is cool to the touch
until yes if you don't have any type of
intimate relationship right well you're
80 years old you've been sleeping
together for 50 years you know but he
thought it was suspicious
um so in that regard I went out and said
no she just rolled over and noticed that
he was cold there's no foul play here
this 80 year old lady didn't whack her
husband you know after marriage for 50
years and if she did without showing
signs of any trauma then good for her
yeah you know they've been married for
for way too long but no yeah so some
national yeah at some point somebody you
got to give her the benefit of the doubt
yeah yeah we'll go out when they
question something like so say on a
scene are the Police or Sheriffs are
they happy to see you or are they do you
sometimes or do they think oh this guy
tries to contradict what we think
usually no no they're they're they
really like when we come out a lot of
times Detectives will wait to hear if
we're responding if we're responding
then there could be something abnormal
then detectives will also come okay
different different agencies use their
detectives in different ways some
respond to all others don't it just
depends on the time and place okay but
there are many difficult scenes to
respond on but they're looking they're
looking to us to help them
um you know rule out Foul Play and other
things like that because you guys have
separate training than they do correct
we're we're medicine based they're law
enforcement based although you know
those guys really
um do a good job as you know especially
the ones that have been there a while
sometimes they'll call things that I may
have not noticed yet you know and
they'll say hey what about this and
they'll also give us a description of
what went on they can look at the
history of that of that subject to see
you know this person's been arrested
several times for drug abuse or domestic
violence Etc so they're giving us
information that we can use yeah on that
scene and on that investigation so yeah
so take me through like an interesting
call that's come in you know especially
down here in Louisiana dang yeah you
know I knew people that could you know
they couldn't learn the alphabet and
they took their own life that's right we
see a lot of that you know there's a lot
of preventable deaths that we can talk
about but you know a typical call in
Louisiana is
um anything from heart disease suicide
OD
um but to be more specific
um
we've had many that they find a body
floating in the bayou and that can be
different you know because they've been
exposed to water so you know they may be
bloated more some of the the surface
evidence or the trace evidence that we
use is not there because they've been
floating you can see where Turtles and
and other animals in the water have
nipped at them oh yeah so it can be
somewhat gruesome and then hard to tell
you know why are they in this water you
know they're dressed in regular street
clothes you know they were swimming they
weren't swimming they weren't fishing
and they're in the water
um sometimes people OD and their friends
have no clue what to do with them so
they throw them into the Bayou
um sometimes these guys are just you
know hanging out and they slip and fall
and hit their head or they pass out you
know we don't always know what got them
to the Bayou now how do those bodies
look if you roll up on a bot because
I've always wanted to find a deceased
body I think a lot of people have bucket
list of mine I see them every day but
I've never rolled up on one yeah yeah
yeah
um is why is that a bucket list thing
for people I don't know but it happens
often I had a guy cutting the grass at a
rent house and found a body God did he
get any Intel or he just got lucky no he
just got lucky he was cutting grass and
boom he found that body a lot of times
if you work and stay focused and you
keep working towards I mean you know
it's better than some lazy dude who's
doing nothing finding a body right at
least that guy's out there and doing
something well when that lazy person
finds about it you got a question how
did you find this body you know yeah
um we had one recently that was just a
driver was passing by and there was a
lady in the ditch now what was
interesting was her arms were removed
she was a Mexican female
damn that's interesting so they removed
her arms because of her tattoos so this
was a Oh the killer this was a hit job
correct and they didn't want her
identified you know so they see this in
a ditch and they call us and then we got
to figure out where's the arms you know
so
um there's interesting cases like that
where people just you know they right
time right place and they find bodies
and so he says did you roll up on that
scene with no arms yes yes so when you
get there what's going on like are
people Milling around is somebody
if you know like what's the scene like
when you roll up on it well in that
regard there's no family's present you
know
um it's different than most you know
it's a lot of sheriffs uh standing
around looking at the dead body now we
have jurisdiction on that body and
legally they're not supposed to touch
that body until we get there okay so of
course I would get there look at the
scene you know to try to find out does
she have family around here what's she
doing in this area she's not from here
um they'll do an investigation the law
enforcement will do an investigation on
the airport and then I'll start looking
at the body for obvious signs of Foul
Play and in this regard she had no arms
so we knew something wasn't right and it
wasn't like an alligator or an animal
came out and removed her arms this was
intentional wow wow you know so in that
case we would get him to an autopsy oh
yeah and do you look for the arms or you
just think just kind of put a note like
keep not like keep an eye out for arms
or whatever like what do y'all do about
the arms you don't worry about it well
the Sheriff's Office and law enforcement
they worry about that they worry about
that okay yeah I mean of course we all
look around the scene to see if you find
anything because there could be evidence
on those arms
um but many times they go you know
unfound
um oh gosh it'd be crazy yeah I mean I
had a guy find a foot once it was from a
from a fatality but they called me and
this was you know Weeks Later hey we
found a foot would you come pick it up
they don't want to touch it even you
know so I throw a bag in my car and I go
grab a foot it's it's it's a different
lifestyle you know yeah you know if I
get pulled over yeah you know carrying
anything uh yeah man I got a foot in my
car
yeah bro I got a 10 and a half in the
trunk absolutely absolutely dude that's
wild man yeah that's interesting and you
put that foot in the trunk you put it in
the back seat what do you do yeah well
in that case I figured it would be
pretty pretty gnarly so I actually
brought a disposable ice chest and
packed it in there and then got it to
the funeral home that they brought her
body to
um she may have been sent to Cremation
but uh either way the funeral home would
take care of that body part okay enough
traveled was with were so you know in
Louisiana it doesn't snow often
they had we had a case years ago where
it was an infant death and the autopsy
places in um
the autopsy place is about an hour and a
half away from our where we live okay or
where we work in our Parish so um they
had a baby that had passed away and they
asked hey it was snowing really bad hey
can you meet us halfway with this child
and I'm in my personal car I'm like sure
so the baby of course is in a body bag
yeah um so I'm driving down the highway
with a with a baby and how big is that
body but I mean it's like a gallon or
something well it's you know it's like a
duffel bag for a baby oh yeah but you
know again you get pulled over and I
have an unmarked car I'm in street
clothes or normally scrubs oh yeah what
do you carrying at least you're not in a
Miata or something yeah yeah you get
pulled over in a Miata and you got a
baby in a duffel bag bro I kind of I
kind of went over the speed limit just
to kind of maybe maybe man if I could
only get pulled over here you know uh it
would be an interesting case but no you
know it's sad for when we lose babies
like that but the fact of the matter is
the baby needed to go to autopsy and
we'll do anything we can to assist in
that regard and if it meant driving
through the snow 30 45 minutes you know
we'll do that yeah that's uh some of the
things that we do to help so your
responsibility then you feel a
responsibility to determine how people
died is that it correct we figure out
why they died we put all the pieces of
the puzzle together okay some are cut
and dry you know
we can look at their medication their
age you know do they smoke drink how
much do they weigh are they unhealthy
you can tell that by their homes too I
mean so I'm a Cajun investigator right
the first thing I look at is their
fridge I don't even look at the body I
walk in the house and I open the fridge
wow and you know when there's Pizza
bones and a spoon and a in a in a jar of
beans and maybe some rotten Popeyes and
a couple of 40 ounce beers I know this
person wasn't living a healthy lifestyle
yeah I know this person was listed in a
mystical too that's right so I'm
thinking heart disease from the get-go
[Music]
so you know again we look at their home
the cleanliness the order of their home
you can tell how people live so a lot of
times the ba the body is is a reflection
of its environment that it lives in
absolutely wow so I was called to one
case where the deputies said um this
one's
um this case is unusual we'd like you to
come out and so then I go out and they
had noticed some blood dripping on the
floor on the floor blood stains out of
the body just in no just on the floor
okay that's all they've noticed right
they saw that and then the body was an
adult male on a couch okay
um so I walked into the house and I mean
we're we're reading everything the
minute we get on scene even even you
know what friends and family are there
how do they look who's their neighbors
uh what area they live in so I walk into
the house and this was kind of in the
country and uh the first thing I see is
he had Mickey's Malt Liquor memorabilia
everywhere so I said okay okay I like
this guy's style you know he's a
middle-aged guy yeah he's a Kappa Sig
probably yeah so I'm looking at that and
then I asked the detectives to show me
the the where the the blood stains are
well I go and I look and there were some
cobwebs over the door so I could tell
that that home hadn't that that area of
the house hadn't been used okay just
from the cobwebs and stuff okay but when
I opened the fridge there was a intact
Hawks head in the fridge with fur on it
I mean that's odd you know and yeah and
then so then I look in the oven and the
guy's making cracklins in an oven now if
you've ever made cracklins you know
you're stirring those in grease when
you're baking cracklins on a Tuesday
night and you save the hog's head to
make Hog's head cheese later you're
going to definitely have heart disease
you know there's no foul play here
fellas and that blood probably came when
he was moving the hog's head from the
kitchen to the I mean from the counter
to the refrigerator oh from the actual
hog you think yeah yeah absolutely so
you know again when you're on your last
limb for a snack you know yeah that's
crazy when you bake in cracklins bro
you're gonna have high cholesterol at a
minimum
um but you know again the blood stains
triggered the law enforcement to to call
and uh the fridge told me the story yeah
as well as the way the guy lived he
smoked cigarettes he had you know
alcohol everywhere
um and Papa Was a Rolling Stone you know
he
that environment told me you know that
what was going on with him right it gave
you a lot of Clues right there yeah
cracklins you got to have the Heat's got
to be so high on cracklins man you can't
do it in the oven I don't think I've
never tried it I I don't know but he was
you know he definitely tried to pull up
how to make crackling see if you could
pull it out I just want to get this
recipe my sister would make them out
there they lived off in Gonzalez so we
make them you get a big large black pot
right you put it out in the yard you got
to cut that stuff up the fire under it
you cut that fat up and then you put it
in grease yeah and you just constantly
stir that grease
porno a pot deep enough that the top of
oil is at least six inches from the rim
place over medium-high heat when the oil
reaches 225 degrees
on a deep fat frying thermometer add the
pork cubes and start stirring to prevent
clumping yeah so it's high oil I guess
you can bake them if you bake them long
enough but
God that's risky though yeah it's just
it can't taste good I don't know yeah I
couldn't imagine it because you got to
really get them to pop and so I just
couldn't imagine them doing it well and
you do dumb when you're drinking
you know maybe it was one of those
nights like hey let's bake some
cracklets yeah who knows let's give it a
run yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know if
it did and then that fella have a wife
or do they seem kind of Lonesome no he
uh he was single he did have a family
children you know on scene but he he
lived alone now say if you pull up on
like let's go back to that water body
right right what happens to a body when
it's in water because I think sometimes
a lot of people fantasize that's one of
the fantasies I'm gonna find a body you
know it's either in the Woods by the
interstate or I'm going to walk down by
a creek bank and there's going to be a
body right there I think that's some of
the general fantasy of humans
um what is that body realistically look
like depending on how long it's been in
yeah so you know
it bloats you get a lot of bloating in
the water the whole body puffs up uh
normally the tongue protrudes out uh you
don't think about that the gases and the
the gases and the decomposer you know
the body sink and then they rise when
when the gases start to to fill up the
body and that's when we find them a lot
of times they'll be snagged in a in
branches on a bayou or in the river
um but that body's gonna bloat a lot and
then again Turtles and other animals out
in the water will start pecking at them
so it looks a little bit more traumatic
than it than it is
um but if we're unsure we can always
send that body to autopsy to try to
determine exactly what happened and
they'll take them apart and a lot of
times they'll cut into their heart and
realize well this guy had a massive
heart attack I see you know so there was
no foul play or he's full of drugs and
there's no external trauma so nobody hit
him in the back of the head and threw
him in there hmm
yeah maybe pull up a little water bloat
for us
oh
yeah so that's you know
online these days it looks like a
Simpsons character huh
he does
sorry to say that I feel that it's a
human being
um oh my gosh so we go from looking
pretty healthy to not healthy pretty how
pretty quickly I mean that's
unbelievable yeah and you know
especially in Louisiana it's so hot and
so humid and you'd just be amazed at
people that live with no electricity oh
bruh if you leave a baby in the yard for
30 minutes bro I'd have algae on one
side yeah yeah I mean it you know it's
um
it's just like that nature really Reigns
Supreme down there it really does
um
with the busy fall season just around
the corner you may be looking for
wholesome convenient meals for
jam-packed days some days you're just so
jam-packed
you're like gosh I'm just jam-packed
factor is America's number one ready to
eat meal kit they can help you fuel up
fast with Chef prepared dietitian
approved ready to eat meals delivered
straight to your door I've had them
what did I have the other day I had a
beautiful little
it was a chicken
um
and a mushroom beautiful little deal I
don't remember exactly what it was but
God it was tasty and I was grateful
that I had it just had to heat it up
refresh your Healthy Habits without
missing a beat choose from 34 plus
weekly flavor-packed dietitian approved
ready to eat in two minutes
that's right and they've got all types
over there depending on what you want to
eat
you know they got calorie smart meals
Protein Plus meals
you can put it together they have
breakfast items as well including apple
cinnamon pancakes bacon and cheddar egg
bites and potato bacon and egg breakfast
skillet
had to factormeals.com
Theo five zero that's right and use code
Theo five zero to get 50 off that's a
lot that's code Theo five zero theo50
the number theo50 at factormills.com
theo50 to get 50 percent off that's
right
factormeels.com Theo five zero blue chew
I've taken them nibblers baby
then edible them them they're uppers
them
they sex uppers that's what they are
if you want to bring the heat
in the bedroom but really if you just
want to be assured that you're going to
have a little extra uh
little extra churn
in that butter maker baby that's what
I'm talking about
bluechoo.com blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra Cialis and
Levitra but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost
the best part it's all done online
so you don't have to go into a dark
alley or go into you know sneak behind
your your uncle's uh Lazy Boy and make a
dirty deal back there
you can do it out in the open
that's right does it work do you think
you need it try it for a month for free
and you'll see you're gonna love it
you could be missing out on the best sex
of your life with blue chew men
everywhere excited to see the postman
because when your packages arrived your
package has arrived wiener
[Music]
that's right and we got a special deal
for our listeners try Bluetooth free
when you use our promo code t-h-e-o at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com promo code Theo to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast
I'm just amazed at how many senior
citizens live with no running water no
electricity in August when it's 100
degrees outside yeah but it's all over
Louisiana you know these these senior
citizens have a hard time uh paying for
their medication much less an expensive
electricity bill and then some people
are just really hardcore on drugs you
know we had a house one time that in the
kitchen there was a piece of plywood and
when the officer slid the plywood back
that's where they were using the
restroom they were in a hole in
the kitchen and then they would cover it
up with a piece of wood I mean that's
that that's pretty hardcore in your home
but you'll see enemies too really you'll
see that you know with people that just
abuse drugs to the point of you know
they're living in condemned homes or
what's that been like with uh the drug
use and stuff like that do you guys do
you guys come up on a lot of like ODS
and stuff what's that has that changed
the way you even approached the industry
I mean how busy has that gotten things
yeah that's um
you know when I first started you know
18 years ago we would have occasional
ODS accidental ODS
um
but that has increased by a thousand
since uh fentanyl has hit the streets
Fentanyl and crystal meth um
the ODS are every day every day you know
it affects every age group you can
imagine you know really the opioid
epidemic came
um and that you know that was started
the the whole opioid thing was started
when the hospital started using surveys
to uh to to compare themselves to other
hospitals it was called The Press Gainey
and one of the the questions in that in
that survey was how did we treat your
pain so and then the reason behind the
survey was hospitals all have the same
equipment you have the same MRI as the
hospital 20 miles down the road all your
equipment's the same but what can you do
better than another and that's customer
service so all these patients would get
these satisfaction surveys in the mail
and I worked in the hospitals and so we
would we would actually skit things so
when they got home they would remember
key words and they would they would rate
US or they would give us a good rating
for instance do you have no did they
have enough time for you in the hospital
so we were are instructed to say is
there anything else I can do for you I
have time so it was this uh it's a plan
as a strategy wow yeah and so then how
did we treat your pain was another one
the Press gaining it was called yeah and
it was a I mean it's a great program you
know it teaches people how to really
people in hospitals how to really you
know go the extra mile for patients we
do things that we don't think about you
know we close that door before we you
know do a test on you so you're not
exposed
um but we don't you don't really know
that we're doing that so things like hey
I'm going to close this door for your
privacy and you know it it's it's it was
a great program but one of the things
was uh pain control so you think that
that was do you think that that was the
motive of the program or do you think
that that was just a side effect of the
program that was a side effect you don't
think that they strategize this program
just in order to get people to be able
to give them to for them to notice okay
for them to get that answer about the
pain right no no not at all it and
it was absolutely a side effect if you
will of that
um Chris Gainey it's called yeah let's
bring it up I don't know if if that's
still a uh they still do surveys of
course right but in the 90s that that
was one that 98 of all hospitals used
um a lot of hospitals were owned by the
the same Corporation so you had five or
six hospitals in your area and they
would do side-by-side comparisons of
each other and we all wanted to have the
highest rating right so your hospital
wants to go for the best rating we're
ranked number five in the nation we're
ranked number three in the Paris two in
the state exactly so this is press
Gainey right here and they are get to
know your patients like never before see
patients from every angle to prioritize
and predict their needs
um if you scroll down a little just want
to see what it is so it's about patient
experience tools yes so this is a
company that helps
uh practitioners I guess know how to
best treat their patients
is that right correct okay press game so
when you go to the hospital even today
when you get home you'll get a survey in
the mail I see and then you know you
fill out that survey and mail it back
same as when you call a t and they say
would you hold you know to complete this
customer service survey but so then you
know how did we treat your pain was one
of them and so then Physicians started
ordering more pain medication not
intentionally to hurt the patient this
this wasn't the the goal
um but you'd get a patient with a broken
arm and instead of getting 15 tablets on
discharge they'd give you 60. so a lot
of the opiate addiction started from the
over utilization of prescribing pain
medication you know a dentist might give
you 40 whereas the 40 hydrocodones or
Lortabs or oxycodones you know the
instead of giving you 10 they would you
know give you 40 or 60. so the
government came in and with the opioid
epidemic and they Tamp that down and put
into regulations so we would we wouldn't
hand out so many pain pain pills we the
addiction Rose by a hundred percent but
it took a long time for them to come in
and do that yeah it did and so because
you guys were experiencing a lot of
Overdose deaths not so yeah yes but you
know the overdoses
um weren't necessarily from just taking
Hydro APAP you know there was always
like a poly drug abuse meaning multiple
drugs being used but those were still
rare at the time we didn't get as many
overdoses as we do now you know I miss
crack the crack days were so much easier
than the new days uh because why is that
because it's that much more lethal
um oh crack is yeah oh fentanyl fentanyl
is much more you know the crack epidemic
was a thing
um but then the the when the pain
epidemic hit that's when we really
started losing people
um so what's the difference between like
a crack death and a fentanyl death well
I mean it's basically going to be a
cardiac event
um fentanyl you know you stop breathing
um that's a very powerful drug the um
the back to the the opioid um the docs
were giving out medication people were
getting addicted and then the government
came in and stopped it and they just cut
everybody off and they made it to where
Physicians could get in a lot of trouble
if they over prescribed and then I think
they came back after that just recently
and said hey we didn't mean not to treat
people with pain because then you have a
lot of people turning to heroin you know
when you're taking opiates and you're on
them for you know five or six years and
you're addicted and then one day you
just can't get any a lot of people turn
to heroin we we really didn't have a
great uh system to get people in to
rehabs you know if you want to if you
want to commit somebody for drug abuse
they have to go voluntarily and you can
imagine that not everyone wants to go
another role of the coroner's office we
have the ability to remove you from your
we can take you and send you somewhere
we're against your will yeah and that's
a that's the other arm of the coroner's
office I didn't know that at all but but
so you get but how do you get those
calls because you think the corner or
death investigators are just getting
called about death so who's calling you
yeah law enforcement they they know that
oh they say hey this guy over here we
need we think he should be 5150 or
something yeah he needs to be in a
hospital okay we need to get him to an
ER and into a psych Hospital can you
guys help us with that right so we yeah
so that we fill out paperwork the
coroner actually signs off on the
paperwork and then the police can go and
remove you against your will and bring
you to an Eeyore but we send all these
patients to the ER and a lot of times
they're let go you know I can have a 18
year old girl that's shooting heroin and
smoking crack and drinking and she gets
to the ER and they say well yeah you
have a problem but drugs are your choice
so therefore I'm going to discharge you
and the the reasoning behind that is we
have a broken system I don't know how
you fix that but so then they get to the
ER and the ER doctors know I can't force
this person to go to rehab yeah you know
that if you want to quit it has to be
your decision
um so a lot of those patients are let go
and then unfortunately we'll get a
coroner call on an OD from one of those
exact patients that we sent to the
Eeyore so you see a lot of repeat
offender a hypothetical it's repeat
offenders when these people show back up
or repeatedly have harmed themselves
with drugs and then a lot of second
third times it's death absolutely I mean
the the
most patients I say most patients a lot
of patients have a psychiatric diagnosis
so when there's a dual diagnosis you can
put them in a rehab in a psych facility
but even that is a five to six day stay
and then they're discharged and then
they have to get home and take their
medication that was prescribed which
they don't so then they end up coming
back through their coroner's office and
going back to the ER you know some of
these guys on drugs there was one that
really really
um
that was really hard to deal with
recently was a veteran
um I know his family they they had
played some audio recordings of this guy
just crying at night
saying he needed help but then he would
turn to meth and get high and then
refuse refuse help yeah I mean this guy
had had kills under his belt you know
and and
we don't want to label people well he's
just a myth junkie I mean these people
all have problems and they didn't they
didn't grow up saying I want to be this
person but this one in particular you
know went to Iraq and killed some people
and now he's back and he's messed up and
he can't make the right decisions and
eventually he'll die but he has to
ultimately agree to go get help so it
it's a hard process on some yeah we lose
we lose people you know and it's tough
waiting for somebody to get well enough
or have enough of a break through their
own Vision or perspective to see that
they need help that's the hardest thing
to try and you can't really influence
anybody you know I mean you can but it's
just
nobody wants to hear that people don't
want to hear often you need help they
this don't accept it you know or yeah
you're just drugged up sometimes
um yeah and you do interventions and
stuff and sometimes people don't want
that I tell families you know because we
have them where you know the families
will send them they'll go to a psych
unit then they'll get out and they'll
die but either by Suicide or drug
overdose and a lot of times I'll tell
families look you have to try you have
to try you can't force your child to go
to drug rehab
a lot of people are nervous about
sending people because the sheriffs show
up and they put you in a core and they
bring you to the ER and a lot of
families just are scared to do it and I
always tell them you know we we don't
know the outcome of this but you have to
try you have to get them in front of
somebody professional and if they get
out and they keep doing the same thing
over and over at the end of the day you
know you tried yeah
yeah man that's such a battle it's
heartbreaking to see the effects of all
that
um of all like the opioid epidemic and
just the all the fentanyl deaths but are
you noticing less of those are you
noticing no so fentanyl deaths are every
day wow every day and it's you know I go
out throughout the state or throughout
the parish and I've been giving lectures
and I'd love to do more uh on Fentanyl
it's a hundred times stronger than
morphine or I forget the exact the exact
uh numbers on that but it's extremely
potent overall drug overdose death Rose
from 2019 to 2021 with more than 106 000
drug overdose deaths reported in 2021.
um and that was during the pandemic
that's involving synthetic opioids other
than methadone primarily fentanyl
continue to rise so imagine a football
stadium that holds a hundred thousand
fans okay uh Tiger Stadium maybe almost
pretty much almost so that's how many
people were losing a year the next time
you watch a football game in a big
Stadium just imagine that many bodies
yeah and that's the ones we know about
you know there's so many unknowns that
we don't catch yeah but we're losing
that many Americans to it and it's it's
young kids
um oh it's unbelievable the the they can
they they have pill presses now so I can
take an oxycodone
a real one and I can take a fake one and
put it in front of a pharmacist that has
40 50 years experience and he can't tell
me which one is real and which one is
fake wow and they do the same thing with
Xanax
um Adderall so all these things kids
take everybody has a crazy ant and
they've heard the word Xanax before so
you have a high school kid maybe the the
girls having boy troubles maybe she's on
her period and a friend says hey take a
half a Xanax it'll help you relax and
that one tablet is fatal yeah you know
and that happens because it's a pressed
pill you're saying it's a pressed pill
right yeah and so pressed pills is where
they basically replicate it but they use
fentanyl up in there correct because it
is more powerful it's cheaper to
replicate than making the actual product
correct you can't get the actual product
so they make it look identical to the
real thing right and people don't know
if you're buying especially you're some
kid you don't know no you don't and you
know what I was told was you can bring
back you can smuggle across the border
of coffee bag a fentanyl versus you know
20 pounds of meth and you're going to
have a higher profit margin on that
little bag of coffee which contains
fentanyl than you would on all that meth
so the cartels are sending in loads and
loads of of Fentanyl and it's it's it's
snowballed into heroin you know so we
see when we were younger you know movie
stars did heroin yeah you know we didn't
see much of that coming up but no I
think you'd have money to do it right
now it's everywhere you know the the
some of the people you just you'd be
amazed at how many
good looking young kids do heroin but
actually it's not heroin you know
there's one form of heroin called China
White which is a snortable formula yeah
people brag about that a lot in the
recovery meeting yeah using that yeah
you can snort it you don't have to shoot
it so what they're doing is they're
selling it but it's fentanyl fentanyl
comes in a microgram a microgram dose so
when you get a milligram dose I mean
that's just a fatal a fatal dose so
we're seeing it every day and when you
roll up on a case like that right where
are those cases at what does that look
like what does that body look like as
you come up on it yeah so they're
normally in a natural position on the
couch or in bed
um but we know you know this person has
had repeated uh run-ins with the law a
lot of times we'll we'll see the
evidence you know they have a belt you
know they've been shooting up they have
their belt they have their syringes and
again nobody touches the body until we
get there
um and we can and I can talk to the
family and get it out of them uh
fentanyl is the worst that we've ever
seen and now they're mixing it with
other drugs like xylazine which is a vet
drug you hear it referred to as tranq
this has created these massive ulcers on
people but they're even having to make
fentanyl stronger when someone dies on
fentanyl the the users in the area you
think they'd be scared of it like I
don't want to I don't want to get that
batch but they want it they want to know
where that person got that batch so they
can get a better buzz from it oh dude
one time I was with my dad and he um
when he would take us to the park and he
would sleep in his car while we would
play it or whatever and uh he gave us
like a like a case of Kit Kat bars or
whatever and we were breaking them and
throwing them out to this squirrel right
and the squirrel ate a bunch of it and
died right and because I guess they
can't have chocolate or whatever but in
the distance dude you saw like 30 other
squirrels hopping over yeah and by the
end of the day bro we'd oh I have to
remember that when we squirrel hunt we
don't oh yeah you get a KitKat I don't
know if it works with that new white
chocolate one but I know like the
original one old school one bro I mean
you could look in the distance of the
park and you just saw them all just
hopping over you know don't tell
somebody from Louisiana that Kit Kats
are gonna Skyward right and that's what
we do we squirrel hunt you know dude
you'll shoot anything if it's in a
freaking tree out there there's a parish
uh if a rope swing gets a little wild
somebody will gun it down there's a
parish in Louisiana and up until
literally a few years ago the school
board opening day squirrel season the
school board closed down so everyone
could go in the woods on that opening
day I mean can you imagine that the
whole town is absent on opening squirrel
season yeah everybody all the men and
kids are in the woods and all the women
are in the bars that's a party you know
uh that's a party squirrels but yeah
um so the fentanyl desk has been high
that's been really really crazy it's out
of control yeah it's out of control od's
used to be you know death is seasonal we
have different deaths in different parts
of the year we know what to expect oh
really yeah so you know um winter time
you're going to get your um you know a
lot of Naturals because the weather's
changing oh yeah you're going to get
hunting accidents you know cajun's
falling out of tree stands right
breaking their neck you know they they
you know everything imaginable in the
woods you got you got Cajuns with guns
in the woods so
um
then you get into
um the springtime weather starts getting
nice in Louisiana we don't have many
many months of nice weather so then here
comes the motorcycles so we started
getting motorcycle deaths a lot of organ
donors right there Lots in the
springtime a buddy of mine's office is
full of motorcycle helmets and I asked
him when they're like why do you have a
motorcycle I mean literally around this
whole office and he'd run an autopsy
clinic and he said I just keep the
helmets on all the ones we do yeah so so
that's a little bit of a collector's
item he's got going yeah so those all
had living people in them that died on
Monday absolutely yeah motorcycles are
dangerous and I'd love to own one but in
Louisiana we have so many roads that
that pop out on major highways and
you're doing 60 miles 70 miles an hour
on a motorcycle and a car pulls out
you're done right yeah you know but we
see that in the springtime summertime we
see drownings so every season brings its
own uh type of natural yeah yeah manners
of death manners of death you know the
holidays are expect the unexpected
really you get for us you get the most
brutal uh you know tear-jerking sad
cases especially around Christmas and
New Year's uh whether it's uh like take
me through something yeah so um a family
you could you know a family dies or or
children a lot of children that
So a family that uh Mom and Dad have
three or four kids three or four kids
are killed two days before Christmas in
a car accident I mean how do you deal
with that as a parent it's hard enough
to lose one much less all but again
that's the holidays we we get these
these heart-wrenching cases I always
tell people to expect the unexpected and
during the holiday time you really have
to be careful in Louisiana we drink 24 7
you know all day oh yeah you know it's
just it's just what we do in Louisiana
and so driving a lot of people going to
Christmas parties and events and pull
out in front of drinking and driving
there's you know there's preventable
deaths and oftentimes I'll tell friends
and family that you know if you have to
go somewhere
and it's a two-lane Highway versus a
four-lane even though it might take 15
minutes longer to get to your
destination take that bigger Highway
where you're not one-on-one with traffic
because I'd guess that 70 of the cars
you're passing or drivers under the
influence and that's all year long I
mean you realize how close you come to
other cars when you're on a back road
you know trying to get somewhere well
especially in Louisiana bro yeah there's
no lights the roads are dark and also I
remember even back in the day man if
when you got out of work you got a
freaking beer yeah you would have you'd
see people all the time driving home at
the stock going across the causeway or
something and they wave at you and they
show you their beer bro it was part of
it's part of the culture I don't know
about anywhere else but in Louisiana we
have places where you can pull up drive
in Windows and get Margaritas that's
just common or you could stick your head
in a stranger's house window and
they'll put a shot of brandy that's
right that's right you know if you need
it so yeah that's just Louisiana bro
it's just part of it you know I think um
so that makes Road road safety that much
more dangerous
um take me on like has there ever has
there been a case like take me on a kind
of a heart-wrenching case
you know and I don't know I feel
horrible even saying that like but take
me on one that really took your heart
out of your body man
um well first I wanna I wanna get my
condolences to the police officers that
have been shot lately uh where I'm from
the parish that I live in Neighbors of
our parishes next to us we own
Vermillion where are you guys in St
Landry okay so Lafayette Parish
Evangeline Parish just in the last week
they've had four three or four
incidences where officers have been shot
and killed uh so it's really sad you
know those are those are always tough uh
police officers are good guys you know
we were all scared of them when we were
younger yeah but you know when you get
to know these guys and they're they're
they're they're all great people and um
it's hard to see I had an officer uh
that was shot years ago and it was such
a surreal thing to zip up an officer in
a uniform he had the black stripe across
his badge I guess that was around 2015
when they started doing those
um black stripes on their Badges and it
was such a surreal event uh to do but
back to uh you know those
heart-wrenching cases for me it would be
friends
family of friends yeah if you had to
roll up on somebody and then it's
somebody you know yeah that's the thing
is when I'm getting to a car accident
you know in
my hometown
um I start seeing cars that I recognize
and as I'm walking up to that to the
wreck you know I I might see a Nissan
Altima or something oh yeah for a minute
your heart drops like oh is that so and
so
um my best friend lost his wife
unexpectedly and and uh
so they had moved in from Tennessee
and he had lost his wife unexpectedly
and that was really hard they had you
know three young children at the time
and it was hard dealing with that case a
13 year old girl
taught me more that night than I mean
still to this day when it was right
around Christmas and I can remember
having to take them to the ER to show
them their mother and
um
it was tough she said uh Mr Toby all I
want for Christmas is my mom and you
know we we put so much effort into
Christmas and presents and holidays and
here I have this 13 year old girl it
really puts things into perspective for
you you know
um and still to this day I do my job
because I was able to save my best
friend's Life by being able to remove
him uh when he was depressed you know
suicide is real
um and he ended up getting help and I
had to I had to help him get help but
you know I feel if I wouldn't have
reacted after that event that he may not
be with us anymore so that's that's what
keeps me going in this in this case so
there's some personal involvement there
in certain situations your ability to
you guys are like oh well if there's
drug use here I can help send this
person or you know help commandeer them
in a direction maybe that could help
them if they're willing to go if there
is like uh if I'm associated with the
the someone who's passed and I'm
associated with a friend I can lead them
into
therapy or keep tabs on them or I've
seen enough instances right where you
you statistically know hey bud there's
probably a 50 chance you're going to
stay alive after you've lost this person
in your life you
you really need to keep tabs on yourself
or get some help absolutely wow
absolutely
um that Tony I didn't know the corner
you know I didn't know some of the
access points that they had and some of
like the direction signs that uh that
the coroner's office can point people in
you know I don't think about that you
just think about somebody rolling up you
know and making a call you know right
you know Satan's line judge you know you
rolling up and you're just the referee
you can call them into heaven or you
call them out you know only the coroner
can arrest the sheriff and that's from
the early on you know 1900s if not
earlier so want to share the sheriff
needs to be arrested only the coroner
can go out and do it which is
interesting
um yeah there's all kinds of things that
we do there's also sexual violence and
and when rapes are involved that goes to
the coroner's office and they do you
know we normally send people to get
raped kits done but uh domestic violence
and things like that also fall under the
corner umbrella we do a lot of things
um and is it straight rapes or gay rapes
like do they all happen
um it would be uh
well I guess they all happen but
I don't know how to answer that one when
a woman is assaulted and it could be a
woman or man absolutely wow absolutely
we'll refer them uh you know to a to an
Eeyore where there's the appropriate
staff to do that uh yeah we're rural
we're a rural coroner's office you know
so now how can they Trump how can
somebody trick you how do they trick the
corner say if somebody say there's a
police officer or something right say or
somebody in a town wants to trick the
corner a body is deceased uh okay and
they want to
and maybe they did it right or there's
some Espionage going on how do they
trick how do they get it past the corner
because I've heard that if you can trick
the corner sometimes you could get away
with murder
that would be a true statement but it's
hard to trick the coroner right
um
I don't know that well if someone does
we had a case for instance where
um
the the wife shot the man and he was
laying there deceased he was a former
there was a shovel on the ground and you
know
Farmers don't put their tools up dirty
they're going to clean that shovel
before they put it up so there's a muddy
shovel laying on the side of a deceased
man
and uh the the wife said it was
self-defense
so
when we walked up to the shovel we just
picked it up and dropped it from you
know two or three feet and all the dirt
fell off so you mean to tell me you shot
him twice he we could see that he
grabbed his wounds
and so did he lay that shovel down nice
and gently after you pumped a few in him
yeah you know or did you stage that
there so things like that you know that
always don't make sense you have to
really think about some of those things
but we have ways we can tell if let's
say you strangled someone or used a
pillow you know there's no yeah you know
that's a that's one that's often thought
about when we're doing our assessment we
can see a thing called petechi so it's
basically retinal hemorrhaging so when
we look into the eyes we'll see little
red dots and we know that that person
was strangled or suffocated
so let's just say uh you know I kill
somebody and then I hang them well I can
tell if they if they were breathing when
they were hung versus not and that's all
based on that retinal hemorrhaging
really yeah so so we have a lot of uh
another thing is uh lividity the liver
mortise so once if you die laying on
your back
um after a few hours your your your body
will appear red on the surface that's
laying on the ground because blood when
it stops flowing drops okay so if I walk
into a house and you're laying on your
stomach but your back is red
well somebody moved that body for sure
you know so we can tell when people try
to you know and a lot of times it's they
rolled them over to do CPR you know most
of the time it's Innocent but there's
ways to tell so that's when the
forensics come into play you know we we
look for deception when we're talking to
people we get stories from family
members and even social media you'd be
surprised that since the uh evolution of
social media that how much that helps us
yeah I saw in that they had that case in
South Carolina that Murdock case or
something yeah you saw that or not where
the man allegedly killed I think he was
convicted of shooting his wife and son
but they had some social media of the
kids where it was just it had been a few
minutes earlier and they could hear the
dad's voice in the background so they
determined that they had been in the
same space at the same time or something
cell phones you know Facebook you know I
have I've had a case where the guy
posted I'm sweating like a horn church
and then he's found deceased and he's
holding his chest well that tells me he
had a heart attack after I examine him
and rule out Foul Play you know maybe
maybe an adult saying man you know
people like to say you know how bad they
feel on social media my legs killing me
today well we can tell if they threw a
blood clot by so when somebody throws a
blood clot they have this cyanotic or
bluish color from the nipple line up and
that's that tells us okay they threw a
blood clot let's throw a blood clot well
so uh basically a piece of fat
gets clogged up in your pulmonary and
cardiovascular system and you can die I
mean there's it could happen to any one
of us at any second of the day oh God I
mean you just throw a blood clot it's
called a pulmonary embolism and what you
do right when it happens what do you do
if you want to live
you start CPR
but sometimes you can't save them I mean
most of the time it's really hard now uh
there are tests that can determine if
you're likely to have one so they start
showing blood thinners okay you know
very common that people are on blood
thinners people with heart disease
um they'll we can manage that with blood
thinners but you can't stop them all
depending on the size of the clot yeah
it's called a DVT deep vein thrombosis
and the majority of people in Louisiana
what happens is the veins in the legs
narrow oh yeah I've seen something and
that's from anything from nicotine to
poor you know high cholesterol bad
shrimp oh yeah bad shrimp too much
Boudin cracklins you know all your
arteries and veins get clogged up and
there's not much much room for air there
so a piece of fat breaks off and you're
out lights out damn you know we've had
people in the ER I mean I'm sorry and I
see you they're there for a blood clot
and they code and there's not much we
can do to save them but
you know we'll look at social media and
the person might say you know hey I just
recently had a surgery on my leg or my
knees been throbbing or my legs are
throbbing or my calf is you know swollen
yeah people post all kinds of things
yeah so that can help us paint that
picture
um as to what may have happened in the
death
some of you guys have seen me in the
past on social media
uh cooking up a beautiful little steak
or a little cutlet in a um
and a pan a real a pan that looked like
it had been through the Civil War
something you know it was like an
infantry style pan but that has changed
for me now
that I'm using hexclad
and today's episode is sponsored by them
the Revolutionary cookware company hex
clad
when choosing pots and pans you used to
have to pick between the performance of
stainless steel the durability of cast
iron and the convenience of non-stick
but with hex clad you can finally have
it all
hex clad's patented technology finally
gives you the benefits of all three in
only one pan that's right
and I'm telling them when you when
whatever you bring into these pans if
you're trying to make you a Booyah base
or a sofa lay
if you're trying to make a curry or
um
reggaetoni
whatever you trying to make they will
this will get it done all of hexclad's
products are backed by a lifetime
warranty that's right you will literally
never have to buy another set of pots
and pans for the rest of your life
some would say that Gordon Ramsey is the
toughest critic in the world and these
are the pots and pans that he uses get
10 off with the code Theo at hexclad.com
that's 10 off at
hexclad.com with the code Theo Bon
Appetit let's eat with hexclad's
revolutionary cookware this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp
that's right
I've gotten therapy I've gotten better
help
um you know I've had times where I
wasn't seeing
the world as comfortably as I should be
you know and it wasn't just a little
thing it wasn't just something that I
knew would pass it was something that
that was building and gaining momentum
inside of me and it kind of scared me
you know if you're struggling if there's
something that's off it's
I mean we're humans
we have a voice and we need to use that
and we need to get feedback from someone
who knows what they're talking about
Better Health can help set you up with a
licensed professional
that's right it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time there's no charge
and I want to iterate that if if you are
going to a therapist and it's super
comfortable and easy
but nothing's changing then that might
not be the best scenario
you can always try a new one here or
there you can go back to the first one
if you want
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's right that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo this episode is
sponsored by betterhelp esta disfrutando
De Mi podcast
thanks to Babel I know what that means
do you
well recently I've been learning to
speak Espanol
Spanish with Babel and you can too
because with Babel you can start
speaking a new language in just three
weeks that's it Babel offers it
tresemmanas you know what I'm saying the
best way to learn a language is through
immersion living where the language is
spoken natively and using it every day
one in five Americans have learn a new
language on their bucket list if that's
you check it off the list this summer
with Babel
because with Babel you start speaking a
new language in just three weeks that's
beautiful wow
science says our ability to learn new
languages Peaks when we're children
but since you can't go back to being a
six-year-old Babel is the next best
option here's a special limited time
deal for our listeners
let's get you started right now get 55
off your Babel subscription but only for
our listeners at
babbel.com
Theo get 55 off at babel.com Theo
spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Theo rules and
restrictions apply
I had a corner so yeah I guess there's a
lot more to the corner than I thought
you know there's a lot of avenues going
on over there it's a lot of
Investigation yeah into very basic stuff
like home appearance body appearance you
know weight where they compliant with
their medicine did they see their doctor
um did they go to the doctor often uh
there's so many things that that we can
tell about a uh just someone that's
deceased now what about like a suicide
like say there's like a hanging or
something you know what's that kind of
how what does a body look like I feel so
morbid asking about some of this
yeah well how much would you be
surprised what bodies look like from
certain events that's what I think I'm
Mo because in my mind I think you I
Envision walking up on a body and it's
still like oh yeah there's you know
that's Jerry right you know but would
you even know a lot of times who the
person is absolutely you can tell who
they are things that change in their
eyes we call that fixed and dilated okay
their eyes are open and staring into
space their pupils have dilated
um so you know their their face kind of
has a different appearance or we can
tell by their eyes that they're not with
us
um
that's actually what he's looking at
there is the retinal hemorrhaging wow so
if you try to smoke uh if you try to
suffocate someone or when they hang
they'll have those retinal hemorrhages
from from the uh from the veins in your
eyes yeah and you know you can't breathe
so it causes those hemorrhages to form
but bodies look like bodies you can tell
you know it's
suicides are tough
um
you know there's uh
they're supposed to leave the body
hanging
or in its natural state until we get
there we need to look at the ligature
marks which is actually the Rope where
they made the knot where's it at and
then of course it bruises the body so
when you have a perfectly symmetrical
um line on their neck you can tell if
somebody maybe grabbed the wire and
choked them and used Force to do that
because it's an even line but when it's
not even and the ligature Mark is
consistent with how they were hanging
then we can tell and there's you know
either there should be petechi eyes so
we know that this person
died by hanging one of the you know and
we use humor it's it sounds bad but we
use humor to get through some of these
cases we had a police officer interview
and he said the same thing he goes
sometimes you'll see cops standing
around laughing they have to do it you
have to because what you're dealing with
is is really hard to see so you we're
not you don't pick on the you know you
don't make jokes about the deceased yeah
per se but you know you joke with the
officers and you try to lighten the mood
some everybody can relax a little bit
more
and one thing for hangings is you always
put the rookie on the front of the body
so when you have to cut a body down
um
you know you can't just cut them and let
them drop you want to protect their body
so you put the rookie cop in the front
and so when you cut that rope you gotta
catch it that last little bit of air
comes out of their mouth and so that's
the worst place to be standing is when
you're actually removing someone from a
rope because they exhale
it's that last yeah it's an apartment on
the front exactly and it's right and
it's rough so oh yeah that's a long one
brother so when you say Hey you know uh
put John on the front everybody that has
experience knows that's not where you
want to be dang and who catches them you
got to catch them well the you know
everybody kind of helps who's there
whoever is around Oh I thought it was
like the bouquet at a wedding or
something yeah sometimes it is
um we rely on the fire department and
those guys do a great job we have bodies
that are you know um house fires or or
more more so
um motor vehicle accidents where the
body's been burned beyond recognition
and they're stuck to the seat you know
we can always call out the fire
department and those guys come and you
know cut bodies out of cores and they'll
help us put them in the body bags same
as as you know decomposure you know you
get bodies that that have been in a home
with no electricity for three or four
days or weeks and the body is basically
liquefied really I mean it's like a
skeleton with like a puddle near or what
is it like is it yeah it's you know it's
it's
like really sunburned and Bloated and
seeping fluid and um it the worst smell
you could imagine I mean everybody says
when you smell death you'll you'll know
it if you smell it again
um but you know scraping those bodies up
is tough you know and sometimes you you
know it's a large person you got to get
the fire department out recently I had
one that was up a staircase that uh like
kind of like the one you have here that
spins up and the person was 300 pounds
so we had to call in some extra muscle
to get that subject down you know so
fire department really comes out and
helps us and how big is a body bag if
it's a body big deal I'll make big bags
yeah they make you know small medium
large and extra large you know for those
people you ever needed to you ever
needed to double bag somebody
um yeah it depends on the body bag
itself
um
we can do things to you know when it's
really messy uh suicides uh gunshots to
the Head we can wrap the heads in bags
before we put them in the body bags and
things like that and that body bag in
some ways is a very very sacred thing
not sacred that's the wrong choice of
words but that's where all the evidence
is so if you're working a homicide when
you put that body in that body bag and
seal it only we can do that and once
it's sealed it's not allowed to be
broken until it gets to the autopsy
facility because you'll have evidence on
that body you know even the maybe the
sheets they were laying in and all that
can go into a body bag and we've had
cases where the funeral homes uh you
know for whatever reason wanted my new
body bag so they would take the person
out of the body bag and put them in an
old one that's patched up with duct tape
and send them to autopsy and you can't
do that just to save the money because
they wanted to get yeah that's a nice
bag I'm going to keep that one and throw
them in this one you can't do that
that's that's that's really important
evidence you know so but
not you know we body bags are or an
important thing that we use sometimes
it's just to get the body out where
there's a lot of people around so we'll
put them in a body bag or on the side of
the road we'll have them put in the body
bags but they're also uh used in the
collection of evidence and so when you
open a body bag out getting everything
in there and an officer walks through
the body bag it's like man you just walk
through my my evidence are you shocked
sometimes by like the ineptitudes
sometimes of certain newbies or just
whatever on forces yeah and you know you
learn to deal with it not people just
don't know they don't know what they
don't know agree man but I've had you
know I've had so when I see an officer
struggling in a home and the smell is
really bad if I see you struggling I'm
gonna slow down because I can deal with
it I've I've trained myself to where the
the smells and things don't bother me
but you know I'll watch that officer
kind of eyes are getting watery their
their face is red they don't like where
they're at and I'll kind of slow my
investigation down like what's his date
of birth and oh let me go dig for that
so just as a way to kind of help them
what no I put them through it I put them
through it you know I'll slow down when
I see them struggling you're going to
make them put them on the grill a little
yeah that's right that's right you know
do you know where his last address was
oh I just want to get out of here yeah
you know but I've had officers throw up
on bodies really right on top of the
body yeah and we're sending that to
autopsy you know so it's like you just
put all your DNA on there it's like a
baptism at Arby's baby right there
that's horrible yeah well speaking of
Orbeez we can talk about that one later
but what happened there was a death at
Arby's yeah in Lafayette oh of course
they found a lady in the cooler did they
yeah yeah wow yeah we got the meat huh
yeah I mean poor thing though she she
was she was uh
she was stuck in there
and she got stuck on accident yeah I
think the lock
malfunctioned and they found her the
next day but that was in a small town
ooh there's a dead body in Orbeez I mean
even my brain went to oh man did
somebody put her in a freezer I'm not
thinking I'm not thinking walk-in cooler
I'm thinking small cooler here we got it
right here New Iberia uh Arby's manager
who died in the freezer
um the family's attorney inspected the
Arby's this week and is now telling all
as part of his inspection attorney Paul
scrabanic locked himself in the Arby's
freezer to get a sense for what she went
through in her last moments the
thermometer read between negative 20 and
30 degrees as soon as they open the door
I got a feeling that I didn't want to be
in there with the door shut
pierces your clothes you go stiff
he was in the freezer for four to five
hours is that what it says go back
schematic says oh the woman was in there
for four to five hours
employees I was uh that they're
it's under my understanding from talking
to one of the employees that there was
that was there with her son when he
found her that she completely Frozen wow
hypothermia do you think that's a nice
way to go kind of no not at all I mean
look you you know you ever get cold I
can't imagine you know what that poor
lady had to deal with yeah
in that in that circumstance
and her son is just white yeah it's
tough
um what does that body look like did you
roll up on it no that was in another
Parish but you know I'm I'm sure she was
cold and stiff with you know
um but pretty normal what position do
people die in a lot is there is there a
lot of you I've always fathomed that I
would be holding my crotch I know that
may sound crazy yeah but I think it's
like a protective mechanism you know
like right I think I would be like yeah
just holding your figs and
yeah or like maybe I don't know where my
head would be but or
um you'd think you'd rather die with
your mouth closed or open what is like a
cooler not cooler but like what's like
yeah I mean we find bodies and all you
know a lot of people collapse fall face
forward a lot of people in bed I think
mouth open probably yeah
like you know then you're almost like
yeah opera singing yeah something we're
like hey bro you know we find them we
find bodies or a lot of guys holding
their junk ah some not not all but it
happens sometimes yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah I always wonder is there
a position that's bad say I'm gonna die
right right and the only the last thing
that I can do is be helpful to
the people are going to find my body and
to the coroner's office what's the best
way for me to die to make it easier on
whoever's gonna
the best to make it easy on you guys and
the staff well I guess uh die in a bed
you know okay that that's the easiest
way that's the best way it's clean you
have covers over you it's easy for the
family yeah families oftentimes want to
see their loved one we have to clean
them up to a degree sometimes they can't
see them you know because it's such a
morbid picture
but you know um dying in bed is very
common on your back
um one time I had a guy a guy die
standing up and I'll never forget that
they called me out to uh an apartment
complex somewhere and so as I'm walking
into the to the scene with one of the
sheriffs a friend of mine
they're like well that's him and we're
not quite in the house yet and he said
he's standing right there and I said
what do you mean he's standing well the
guy died standing up
and I for a minute I thought they were
messing with me I'm like y'all up y'all
got to be messing with me so I even like
tapped him on the leg before I yeah you
know he had just the way he had fallen
he was standing up at a sink in his head
just kind of landed on the he just kind
of wedged himself in and his legs were
locked and that's how we found him that
was so odd you know
that's interesting yet if he really just
kind of locked in there he's just
getting his steps in I guess
I don't know if he was brushing his
teeth or what what that was but oh I
didn't I didn't believe him I'm like
that can't be him and they were like I'm
telling you he's standing up and said
well that's that's one that's one for
the books yeah because what are the odds
that it's like when you watch those
videos of those people trying to throw a
bottle in there and make it land you
know right right I've only had one die
standing up in 18 years oh wow so it's a
rarity that's very rare yeah in my
opinion you know now and how tough is it
like you like if there's ant do you guys
ever deal with animal Animalia death
yeah so do you guys just Corner deal
with that too or no yeah we deal with
all all deaths
now don't get me wrong we've had people
call us because they have a dead dog or
they got bit by a dog and it's like oh
you're calling the coroner's office huh
yeah go to the ER yeah call your
neighbor and call him an yeah
you know that's what's happening but no
um animals well so if you die in a home
that's locked with animals those animals
will eat you really fast especially a
cat dogs will hold out until they they
have nothing left to eat but a cat will
remove your head in 24 hours and I'm not
talking I'm talking literally hair on
the floor no head and nibbling into
their chest even cats that were loved by
their owners or is it just cats no do
you think we're had something with the
owner and they're and they're gonna say
this is my time yeah no they're they're
absolutely feeding on you you know I
don't care how much you love that cat
and that cat loved you he's gonna eat
you and you know sometimes we get to
cases where there's uh you can tell that
the cat or dog had been nibbling you
know it might be on the face or the
cheek or so uh the toes but then
sometimes it's unbelievable and one of
it was one of my first cases and I just
never never imagined that they could do
that much damage smaller dogs now a lab
a lab won't a labs for some reason don't
eat their owners you know unless they're
locked in for months I guess they would
but I find it more weenie dogs small
dogs and cats cats cats don't they don't
wait you know it's like a around
a barbecue pit a Cajun I should say
around a barbecue pit they smell that
that odor and they start nibbling so
yeah yeah they want to appetizer next
time you petting your cat yeah just know
that when you die he's gonna eat you
he's gonna pet you back with his teeth
absolutely what uh and how how soon
after we talk in 30 minutes after yeah
probably a hour or two I guess they
start nudists they start nibbling and I
love my cat you know we have cats and
dogs how could you still love your cat
knowing how they're gonna do yeah I
don't care if they eat me after I'm dead
you know that's cold as hell bro well
think about that man my buddy died bro
we've been friends forever right he's
laying there dude and I carve a
little bit of them off yeah it's pretty
intense I make a sandwich or
something out of my boy Randall
yeah well after an hour they do it they
do it you know I'm kind of new to cats
we just got one to keep the mice down
but yeah oh you're gonna keep the mice
down or he got along he's playing the
long game though dude yeah that's when
they lay on your wrist they check in
your blood pressure dog that's what that
cat is yeah they're waiting for you
they're licking their lips wow as is the
weenie dog but weenie dogs will do it
too yeah small dogs I find that small
dogs or they'll jump on jump up on the
lap of their owner and you know I guess
start nibbling and we'll eat the wheat
the wiener to jump too or not I've never
seen one but absolutely absolutely you
know most of the time it's uh I kind of
feel like they're nudging you to see if
you're still alive you know maybe
licking you at first and then when you
don't respond and then they just start
you know they just go after it it's
pretty intense
and what about like a turtle if say the
body's in the wild it's in the water or
something did they eat the junk they eat
the junk off a body or not well usually
the body's covered so it's going to be
it's going to be arms oh okay so it has
clothes yeah you you you're going to
have pants on and how big was your waist
get if you get bloated say I'm like a 34
35 inch waist how big would yeah you can
go to a 43. you know wow in the bloating
stage the body's uh my buddy Thomas I
think he's like a 43 or something they
they you you do swell and get a lot of
Edema and then it starts to almost
liquefy we've had cases where we've had
to we have to move the body or pull that
body out and I've grabbed the leg of
somebody and when I pulled everything
came off all the skin and you put the
whole leg off yeah you know not it
didn't detach the leg but all of a
sudden no I don't think it would have
pulled the leg off but all the skin just
just you know that does happen but the
body's so frail at that point you know
what is the do you think you have some
infatuation with death why are you able
to handle this sort of thing I couldn't
handle some of the images that we pulled
up right yeah I mean really you know
like what what makes you think you're
able to digest that visually and um
emotionally and everything and how does
it digest for you yeah you know I
started Healthcare really young in life
High School
um all my friends were taking shop and I
decided to take a nursing aid class I
figured I'd be able to bathe the girls
well that didn't work out so well that
body shop homie I should have talking
about I should have took shop but that
would work
but always had a fascination with health
care and then I went into other things
and at one point uh cardiopulmonary
respiratory therapy so we manage life
support systems so okay so then you're
getting close to death so yeah an edge
right there RT does deals with trauma
you know where the the airway in that
regard so we're involved in in every uh
traumatic death RT when you say that
respiratory therapist okay are always in
the ER working for major codes and core
accidents and things like that so you
were around a lot of that so yeah I mean
we've managed the life support system
sometimes we have to pull the plug or
turn the machine off and um that's what
you see you'd have to actually pull the
plug yeah well you turn them you just
turn the power off but yeah
um you'd think you'd at least pull the
plug like at least it's essentially you
do I mean you have to take the machine
out but
you know terminating life support on
somebody
um
by the time you're at that stage they've
done brain tests to see if there's any
brain activity and these people don't
want to live on a machine you know it's
not like they're alive and talking to
you right at that stage but again we see
all you know we
we see a lot of trauma and I've always
had this uh I've always wanted to see I
wonder what paramedics and police see
um you know I wonder what what people
look like when they don't make it to the
ER
um I can remember having a uh my brother
was in the Iraq War the first one a long
time ago and he brought back some
pictures and he had some pictures of
extremities and things and I was just
fascinated to see that I don't know why
I was born that way I just I but I was
really fascinated to see some of that
and then a la carte huh yeah and so then
later in healthcare and seeing trauma we
don't you know for someone that's not in
health care yeah it's it's hard to see
and imagine but
I don't you know I don't necessarily see
my eyes or I'm looking at science and
Anatomy you know that's just a femur or
that's just a brain this is parts of the
anatomy that that you know we've that
we've you know studied and seen before
yeah so it's not like I'm I'm seeing you
you know I'm not seeing Theo I'm seeing
right you know I just in general brain
and knees and whatever yeah I mean
people say how can you be a coroner
because you see bad stuff well an
orthopedic surgeon will take your arm
off and they're dealing with blood and
you know all kinds of things and they
remove your arm and then put it back on
you know so it's the same thing uh kinda
um
it's just what we see do you ever feel
like so you determine the time of death
yes wow and how do you know if you get
it right or whatever like does a buzzer
go off or something like how do you
that's actually tricky you know to the
exact time of death okay
um there are things that can be done
um you can do a a liver temperature
um you can you know the the stage of
decomposure if there are maggots and
bugs on the body that can give you a
window of how long they've been down you
know flies lay eggs and then you can
even take the maggots and send them to a
lab and they can tell you what their age
is and that can help you determine time
of death but that that's a bit extreme
we can there's other ways you know when
was the last time you spoke to to so to
to Johnny you know when was the last
time anybody saw him
um what were his complaints when you saw
him uh when was his last Facebook post
when was his last phone call so you can
kind of get a window into that time of
death even rigor mortis you know it
comes on and then it lets go and there
are certain time amounts on that so we
can figure out you know an approximate
time of death you know unless you're
working in the ER and they stop
breathing or the paramedics are there
because maybe they're sluggish but
they're not completely deceased
um you know that's an exact time but
other than that it's a it's a it's a yes
based on evidence
when they called us we issue a time of
death it's when they contact us so we
get called on Johnny by a nurse in the
ER or a police officer and I immediately
look at my watch and say okay time of
death is 10 15. that's not the exact
time they died but that's when they
notified us so close enough yeah and if
you get it right do you get you know get
like a notification on your phone like
nobody no there's no reward or anything
for getting it right no I'm not no not
now it does help the attorneys and when
there's lawsuits happening or
um you know they need to get as close to
the time of death as they can for
homicides because then it puts people in
different places you know where were you
at 10 50 you know
um
so it's that you know that's why
sometimes it's really important to know
as close as you can get to that actual
time of death
and is there like a tote you guys do
actually you always hear about toe tags
right people put a toe tag on a body is
that true so we don't put it on the toe
but you know labeling that body is very
important if I'm going to send you to
autopsy I don't want to mix you up with
someone else or I don't want to send you
with nothing and then they you know I
always type a report on my death
everything I see I have to type and put
into a report so when that pathologist
is reading that report
I'm painting a picture for him and that
helps him in his in his autopsy in fact
I brought you one I brought you a your
own personal toe tag here now I want to
hang that on the wall
uh gosh this is uh I can hang it on your
toe if you want but if I sitting I don't
know if my mom would be happy if I
accept this right now
oh to be determined to be determined
yeah yeah you also put that under sex
yeah so well I have you I think I have
you and Nola
that's good yeah that's where I was born
at so yeah I could see myself dying over
there bro that's a great conversation
piece you know yeah it is actually
that's not a bad dude I thank you yeah
pretty sweet of you bro dude you
speaking of New Orleans during Hurricane
Katrina did they bring in a lot of
Corners to help out what happens when
there's a natural disaster like that
yeah we can you know uh did you get
called in I I didn't go to New Orleans
um actually I volunteered for Lafayette
because there was a lot of not coroner
but Health Care in general oh I see so
there's still yeah there's a lot of
other recurring deaths and even in the
outlier areas yeah I'm just thinking of
Katrina because it was one of the more
known hurricanes I think what else was
there Ida I'm trying to think what else
was over by you guys hurricanes yeah I'd
uh there were some in Texas if there's a
big natural disaster is it like all hand
we need all Corners to this part of the
country does that ever happen um well
there we do have protocols you know if a
plane falls out the sky and there's you
know 100 people uh we do have protocols
we can reserve a cooler truck we can
call Walmart and say hey one of your big
you know freezer trucks can we you know
borrow one
um there's a whole team of people that
were prepared for that mass shootings
and whatnot it's important to identify
who each person is so we can contact
their families and and you know
um
yeah we had a uh you know I've worked
with the NTSB on an airplane we had a
little little it wasn't a lot of bodies
but what is NTSB so that's the the
that's the uh when a plane goes down
it's the federal agency that
investigates plane accidents okay and
that one wasn't unique because we had a
little small Cessna that fell out the
sky and um you know those guys come in
and do their own autopsy and it's
amazing from just wing damage of the
plane they can tell you exactly where
that plane was going and what direction
to try to figure out what went wrong
with that plane have you rolled up on a
plane crash before so I I was called to
one yeah and what was that that had to
be from your own perspective probably
interesting because that's not a common
thing yeah it was it was interesting to
say the least it was you know two guys
and it was actually a tough experience
because somebody was flying over
in in a in another plane and had taken a
picture of that and posted it and then
they took it down so when something
happens in a small town everyone starts
talking hey I heard there was a airplane
accident or a motorcycle accident where
everybody thinks of their loved ones and
in this case family was reaching out
yeah to the deceased and it's hard to
watch that phone ring and just stare at
it and know that you know this person
you know is trying to get a hold of
their loved one that one that that can
be tough
um
to see and you know you just know that
that mother a father is trying to get a
hold of their son so that probably
happens often then you're at a crash
site and there's a ringing phone right
or any yeah any site you know our news
spreads fast you know yeah I think
Johnny OD'd within Johnny's phone just
starts blowing up you know people are
trying to call him I mean I lost my best
friend and um we didn't have phones back
then but trying to contact them so
that's very common that phones will just
ring and ring and you don't you don't
want to make that notification over the
phone you don't no you want to send an
officer out there or sometimes we'll go
with them but you will yeah we we don't
have to but I've done several
ride-alongs it's not a not an easy thing
to do
um
you know when we when we go out to a
scene we're often forgot and we're the
the last responder right when we go out
and and your loved one is deceased
whether it's sudden or natural families
are in a different mindset uh they you
know rarely remember us you know from
that that case and I always give people
my personal cell it's like look you're
going to have questions later oh you
know call me I'm gonna you know I'll sit
with your family and tell you exactly
what went on have you ever had someone
try to call you and like just like lost
and like trying to like get you to bring
their loved one back to life like if you
ever had any
um no but I've had them I've had people
look you know maybe you didn't look at
this one right or not believe the cause
of death and I can't share all that
information you know I can't share
everything that I see and find
um with the public so I'm a hundred
percent right but some people maybe it's
a suicide and they don't believe that
this person would have done that and
they're you know did you did you
investigate for a homicide and it's like
well believe you me that's the first
thing I do you know
um so we do get those calls from time to
time
um the hardest part and we were talking
about suicides earlier you know the
blood and guts don't bother me
um
but when for me anyway when I read a
suicide note that's what sticks with me
I can remember everyone I wrote I've
read for some reason it's personal at
that point not hey I'll be in the barn
come find me in the barn you know maybe
a child emails their suicide report uh
note to their family and can you imagine
and and or just a long letter it makes
it more personal and that sticks with me
longer than anything else and what is
what are those entail a lot of times if
you're looking through them notes what
are they putting in there
well you know don't blame yourself kind
of thing
um I'll always be an angel on your on
your shoulder and just your real
personal things you know I didn't do
this because of you or you know it's
it's
for some reason that sticks in my brain
more than than the actual scene
um
yeah it's just hard to deal with
sometimes you know that that changes the
the mood if you will
has there been a debt that was really
just blew your mind and how tough it was
to deal with that's something that maybe
it attached to something you had
personally in your life or an experience
to help you learn about yourself yeah
that's the that you know those are when
you'd ask me about personal ones I guess
when I see
um you know I have children and when
maybe like not that long ago I had a a
22 year old lose his dad and to watch
that 22 year old walk up to his father
in an ER you know I could imagine my
children coming to see me and and it you
know those hurt same as with babies and
you know uh all those things are hard to
see they really take a toll on us and
you know there is no out for us we have
to deal with it best we can
um they're not always easy you know my
Escape is music I listen to music on the
way there and I'll listen to music on
the way back and it's on the way home
and it's two different types of music
depending on what I've seen but we all
need that escape
uh yeah like what will you put on like
some Creedence Clearwater or what were
you like what kind of tunes are you
talking about or just something like a
like a Mozart or what are we yeah no I
mean my music my music taster all over
the map but you know um heading out to
scenes I'm I'm jamming to some Alice in
Chains or some Metallica And I'm just
getting in there
yeah yeah
I'd like to uh yeah I'm rocking but you
know when I'm leaving I'll go mellow
I'll go I'll go from you know maybe some
Counting Crows to some sometimes uh even
black gospel music I mean my brain just
goes to you know depends on the case and
the uh and what I see but yeah music's
gonna Escape for me you know it gets me
out of that
you know I don't do it I don't do this
full-time we all have other jobs we're
very uh or we're paid off of the budgets
and we don't have much I mean I I
literally when I go out and draw blood
on the weekends or or I virtual fluid
when I get home I throw it in my fridge
at home and the butter and the butter
dish you know my kids know hey Dad and I
found my little boy hey my dad has dead
people's blood in there yeah you know we
we we work around our jobs oh damn
that's Satan's condiment right there boy
damn that's a blast so I mean we we
really serves bro we're really on our
own yeah my kids are desensitized you
know they back in the the early Windows
98 when you could set your screensaver
to to just roll through your pictures on
your computers every once in a while one
would get away from me and it would just
be this really this gory picture and I'd
have to take it down but uh
you know I've
you know yeah my kids are just
desensitized to say the least but they
hear me telling stories about what I'm
working with yeah and so they know how
dangerous drugs are they know
um one thing you know I wanted to talk
about preventable deaths and deaths that
we see too often yeah that's a great
question like if you were a parent if
you were or just a human being you know
you mentioned earlier like the holidays
is kind of a time where you need to be a
little bit more cognizant because things
happen then you know things happen fast
um yeah not to take a two-lane Highway
if you can to four lane it's so funny
after living in a bigger city and you
get back to a smaller place two lane
roads like highways seem so dangerous
it's crazy to think that both of us are
going to pass each other safely with all
the common accoutrements they have
people having cell phones whistles you
know perversion toys or whatever and
some two people are going to go buy each
other at 70 miles an hour safe yeah
those people those people are on
Fentanyl and heroin and Coke and and
mushrooms and you name it and they're
they're five inches from you or your
children or your family you know it's uh
you really see things so for me uh ATVs
and four wheelers scare me yeah
um I've had even seasoned farmers will
die on four wheelers and it's kind of a
thing kids love to ride four-wheelers
and they're just so dangerous if they
flip on you you're gonna break they're
gonna break your neck yeah great
possibility of that the same with uh you
hear of Polaris rain dangers and and
other utvs a four-wheel golf cart like
four-wheel drive things people don't
consider the flip ratios on those things
and I've had you know several cases
where three or four children die on them
you know you may go to Tractor Supply
and get a get a cheaper you know eight
thousand dollars for a you know for a
four by four that you four wheels and
people think well that's safer but the
flip ratios are terrible on those
cheaper ones yeah and they flip when
kids are just riding them in the yard
you know so that's my big thing as four
wheelers I'm scared to death I've always
have been to let my kids ride them just
because of what I see
yeah well I think look you're the guy
who knows you're the guy who's standing
at the finish line and seeing who's craw
who's finishing early yeah and what the
causes of those finishes are yeah and if
you say that it's motorcycles if you say
that it's four-wheelers then that's what
it is you know that's some of the risk
of things
um yeah don't ride a horse if you don't
know how to ride horses Mardi Gras is a
big deal a bunch of people in Louisiana
everybody gets drunk and rides horses
yeah I mean horse throws you off you hit
your head you're done you're drunk on a
trailer you fall off that trailer it
runs over you you're gone I mean we see
Mardi Gras is an interesting time yeah I
literally throw a pillow in the back of
my car because I might be on the road
all night you know we see a lot of motor
vehicle accidents you know and drunk
driving drunk driving you know hold my
beer and watch this kind of deaths you
know where I've had guys trying to jump
other cars and you know Duallys wrapped
in trees 15 feet above above the cement
that that were reduced to the size of a
uh very small core yeah Kia Sophia yeah
so you know Mardi Gras is a interesting
time to say the least uh a lot of
accidents you know obviously you get
brought on all kind of calls and having
a certain level of Hume like um
trying to be keep things humorous if you
can right you know right are there ways
you do that at crime scenes are there
crimes where you've just been like you
guys can't help but laugh at the uh just
the fact that it even happened the
circumstances surrounding yeah
um well one I had it wasn't really a
corner skull but I was called out to uh
death
by a city police officer so I get there
and you know when I again we're in a
parish of 80 000 a lot of people know me
they know what I drive you know I can't
go to a friend's house and have a cup of
coffee without my phone ringing hey did
so and so die I'm like no I'm just
hanging out you know
still alive and well
um but I got called one time and the guy
was still alive they were doing CPR and
he had a heartbeat so I walked as I'm
walking up to the house I see the
families I see their posture change like
you know oh the corners here it's
not good and you know so I walk in and
the paramedic says we got a heart rate
and I'm like
he's not dead yet
who called me so I immediately walk out
and I wave at the family and that guy's
still alive today and you can imagine
them saying you were so sick wow the
coroner came
you know
um those are you know we see crazy
things uh one lady was told to put jelly
she had a really bad infection she was
putting jelly between her legs okay
somebody said put some jelly on it well
she was right what you mean like uh
Smuckers or something well that's what
she was using Okay normally it would be
more of a KY Jelly or something for that
and they her legs were purple and it was
like what what's going on here and her
her neighbor said you know well she was
putting jelly on it and it's like wait
what you were using the smoker that's
the wrong kind of jelly but you know
we've seen wedding rings around penises
it's like man how'd you even get that on
there yeah just wow that must have been
that's a big promise yeah yeah huge
um you know we see bizarre things like
that that people do auto-erotic deaths
or actually very dangerous we we
actually get a not a lot but enough of
them and that's where people are
pleasuring themselves and also hang
themselves yeah they they're starving
their body of oxygen okay and
doing that you need a spotter because
it's so common for people to die yeah
when they're doing that so uh well
if you got a spotter you don't even need
to do it usually well it depends but
yeah I guess yeah people's into
different stuff and people are artistic
people you know bad things can happen in
that regard
um
just bizarre bizarre things now uh back
to the we were talking about animals I
had a call from police and they weren't
sure they didn't see a gun but it
appeared that someone had there was Foul
Play based on the the face and of the
decedent okay and that was just rodents
you know that had gotten yeah so it
looked you know suspicious of a homicide
you know so I don't know if rats get in
there that's right so we can get out
there and say no no this is you know
we'll we'll still send an autopsy to be
sure in some in some cases but don't
make a cheese out of anything huh that's
right post-mortadella that's right
that's right
um I'm fascinated by that cat that took
somebody's head off they'll take
somebody's head off huh yeah completely
completely and where do they hide it
somewhere oh they eat it oh my God no
I'm even bone I mean they eat bone
there's no skull left it's gone it's a
wig on the ground next to a body
um and you can imagine and and down into
the chest I could see their left main
stem from their lung and it's just
amazing how fast the cat can eat you so
you know have a dog door have a cat door
not a bad investment let them leave huh
you know they can get in and out the
house uh as needed yeah we had a lady
that had a cat or a uh she had a panther
living in her house and she didn't even
know this old lady
and it killed someone like a panther
yeah like a real panther yeah she didn't
know she thought it was like a rescue
cat or whatever and it killed someone at
a
surprise party wow imagine that
dogs I've had dog accidents you know I
love pit bulls they're gorgeous
Dobermans
beautiful animals but I've seen people
that they've just reacted and grabbed
their neck and killed them you know
those animals can be great and they can
be dangerous you know what about some
unique animal deaths you ever rolled up
because Louisiana bro you know what I'm
saying anything people some people you
know you know that other than you know
having a good pet having a pit bull as a
pet and it biting the owner and getting
them in the right spot you know that
little alligators no no alligators not
yet now now bodies that have been chewed
on by Turtles and possums and other
animals when they're dumped into the
water that's uh that's hard you know
that's tough
but again that's you know not a whole
lot of animal deaths now riding horses
and not knowing how to ride like I had
mentioned horses can really mess you up
you know if you don't know what you're
doing it's a big animal oh yeah
um at Mardi Gras once I saw two horses
making love when the cops were still in
their back oh wow yeah well we see that
yeah and that's you know somebody joins
the Mardi Gras ride with a horse that
hasn't been fixed a stud and they'll
climb the back you know yeah yeah and
you know that's oh that's harrowing as a
kid seeing your stepdad you know yeah
getting overtaken by some animal Yeah
well yeah that's a that's a thing um and
other crazy cases or anal insertions
it's like what people and what are
people doing it for for pleasure oh okay
you know we would see that a lot in the
Eeyore but I had a case where the guy
obviously didn't want to go to the ER
and so he'd Had A Hammer and was using
the backside of a hammer to put in his
buttocks right right and that can
perforate your colon and then you get
really septic yeah so you know things
like that
um damn that was you know another
interesting case would be um huffing
where people use keyboard cleaner to get
high and those deaths occur in parking
lots of stores
most frequently you're going to find a
hover in the parking lot at Walmart oh
because they get out and and
so I had one guy actually a veteran and
that's how he would stop his nightmares
it was the only thing that worked and so
law enforcement's on scene and they're
like we can't find any drugs but there's
air cans everywhere you know and that's
dangerous the worst is when you think
you're doing like huffing like one of
those things and you actually get one of
those horns yeah I can imagine that's a
wake-up call
that's the Lord trying to say Hey look
it's time to stop yeah I'm gonna rescue
you real quick daddy you know that's the
worst man the um the synthetic drugs
that you see so go next time you're in a
gas station just look around you know
they sell Kratom they sell uh oh yeah
all sorts of stuff my nephew Zaza so
Zaza is words or something what the
look up gas station dope or whatever gas
station heroin yeah
he was on
so there's Kratom and you know there's
[Music]
um
the worst one that I'm seeing now is
well that that's still for sale is
tneptine CNN right that's that's ZaZa
so what that is it's an antidepressant
it's actually a tricyclic antidepressant
that
tags to the MU receptor which is your
opioid receptor so supposedly if you
take one it gives you that opioid
feeling
but you're taking an antidepressant on
and off and in large amounts and that's
very dangerous yeah and and once so I
mean you can take commonly prescribed
Lexapro for a week or two and when you
try to stop you start having these you
start detoxing on this medication so
people that get on that stuff can't come
off it's actually when I was reading on
it it's worse than heroin the
withdrawals from that stuff and speaking
of gas station owners they said people
come in here every day they scrounge up
30 bucks to buy a bottle of this stuff
and they do it every day every day and
kids can buy this kind of stuff they can
go to a gas station and buy some
you know that you don't really
know what it is
when when the the synthetic bath salts
and the synthetic marijuana came around
yeah at first it was a synthetic
marijuana and we didn't really get any
uh there wasn't anything bad happening
but then they outlawed it and then it
came back and that's when it got really
bad uh that's when people and I'd never
seen this but people were chewing other
people's faces off and it it it it
completely changes their their
Psychopathology they just go crazy on it
um and these companies they keep making
them illegal but they keep adding a
different chemical to it so they can
sell it again and this was this was
really we would you know we bad batches
there's never a good batch but we could
tell when there were bad batches because
of the psych units yeah we would get a
lot of people that needed help being
because the bad batches of these guys uh
like weed over those yeah fake marijuana
or bath salts and we'd get calls where
you know Jimmy's in his underwear
holding a crawfish don't talking to God
in the middle of a street and he was on
that stuff I had one guy that was doing
60 miles an hour and jumped out his
truck while driving oh and that's what
he was on you hear of like a Red Rover
with somebody probably yeah well no I
don't know what the voices in his head
were telling him but he bailed on that
truck
um yeah it's dark the things that can
happen man and so
um is there moments where like so say if
you are because you're kind of like you
determine if people are dead or not
right yeah well yeah they're dead I mean
yeah have you ever had somebody and
they're not dead yeah that's well in
that one regard where they still had a
heartbeat but okay but yeah no it's
never uh or they did I mean even the law
enforcement and people can tell you know
when someone's not breathing you never
showed up and be like this guy ain't
even this guy ain't dead no okay no not
yet
not yet if you ever like put somebody in
a body bag and you low-key had like some
like you didn't like that person and you
were like not like you were personally
like I'm glad they're dead but there was
a little party like a because we all
have kind of Twisted parts of our souls
yeah that felt a little bit of joy you
think no no I uh I've never had that
happen even even the biggest enemies
um you know I don't you know they died
their family's gonna be upset it's uh
yeah you know
yeah but I hear you I guess the right
person hasn't died yet right maybe one
day but yeah because I think of myself
as a loving person but I can't you know
we all have we're all very complex
individuals and and uncomplex and so I
think it I'm just wondering if part of
me if I ever put you know
did the just put that zipper up on
somebody if I'd be like yep you know got
him you know or something like that yeah
not yet not yet we try to be as
compassionate as we can and you know
that there's family and children
involved and it's it's tough do you get
invited to a lot of the service and
stuff do you have to go to that thing
are you guys required to go to any
funerals only no not really only for
friends
um really friends and and and maybe
there's a few cases that were just
really hard where the family was
struggling and I'll go in there and give
them a hug
um you know covid was a thing and uh
covet was was really rough really my
opinion on covid
from what I dealt with uh when it
started you know we like I said death is
seasonal and
March April May it eases up that's our
slow time uh we don't get as many deaths
now
you know ODS and suicides and homicides
or 24 7 now I mean that happens every
day but the the the end of spring early
summer is when we don't get as many
calls and I can remember training
somebody and she would say when am I
going to get something good when am I
going to get something good and I kept
saying just be patient just be patient
you know it's like bass fishing you
might have just some normal everyday
stuff and then boom you get a big one
yeah well I used to work fast food too
and I remember everybody wants to do the
fries or something like the first day
you're there right you know well it's
like dude you can't just do that covet
came
and you know we had heard rumors that
there was this virus and we went my wife
and I went to Colorado and we were aware
but it it wasn't out the box yet and
then shortly after we got home
we just started getting phone calls and
phone calls and phone calls I mean I
still have PTSD from talking on the
phone you know in healthcare we didn't
know what was going on people were dying
left and right I'm talking I would have
one Hospital on the phone and I'd have
to say can you please hold and I would
answer the other one I'd have three
calls coming in every hour and that
stayed constant for you know three or
four months just the amount of deaths we
had now Louisiana we have a lot of
unhealthy people oh yeah in general and
when you know covid was the same same
thing every time it was
before the nurse would tell me I'm like
well wait let me guess the patient came
into the ER wasn't breathing you know
put him on a CPAP y'all ventilated him a
while they failed that y'all put them on
a ventilator and the family withdrew
care am I right and they were like yep
you got it it was the same manner of
death every time and it was rampant we
didn't stop now some people saying I
don't believe covid and you're you're
pronounced you're pronouncing these
people and blaming it on covid sure they
had diabetes they were obese they had
all kinds of problems but the volume of
deaths that took off at that time was
unbelievable and it was a lot of my it
made it awkward for my a lot of people I
know my friends I've lost friends to
that uh friends parents you know it was
just it made it awkward I'd go hang out
with my buddy and he knows you know he
knew that I pronounced his father and
there was a lot of that going on during
covid you know people ever get mad at
you for pronouncing their family
deceased no no no but it just kind of
makes a little blame it on you huh no it
but it it does it made it awkward you
know and so when you look back at that
time right because there was tons of
things being said about covid right
right especially you know things like um
oh it's not real right right so you
would dispute that totally absolutely
there's no doubt something came along
yeah I've been up for four days
answering the phone I mean I went
through I saved them I went through five
five subject notebooks in a month you
know it would it was overwhelming did
you think that the like the manner of
like treatment like because a lot then
there was a lot of rumors like oh people
put people on ventilators they shouldn't
have that's what killed them do you
think that there could have been some
and we don't know you know I don't know
a lot of this stuff right you may have
more insight than I do do you think that
as people as the medical professional is
figuring out how to best handle people
that they that that could have
contributed to more deaths I think we
found better ways to treat them and make
them manageable
um you know steroids were the first
thing that popped into all of our heads
because they couldn't breathe we need to
shrink that soft tissue and give them
steroids later they said you know lay in
prone or on your stomach made it easier
to breathe
um ventilators at coming from
respiratory therapy uh when the lungs
get stiff you have to go to a pressure
ventilation and it's actually called
ards ards and it's a it's a acute
respiratory uh failure in adults where
their lungs actually become stiff so
when we're ventilating someone we're
using a volume based uh air to open and
close their lungs but when they had
covid their lungs would stiffen up
and the only way to to truly ventilate
them to get their CO2 down was to jack
up that vent on pressure support on a
pressure ventilation that is if you're
sending in a pretty uh what a what a
pretty high PSI you mean yeah we yeah we
we were ventilating them with air
pressure instead of just that volume
flow based and we had to that was the
only way you could get their lungs to
open and close and then eventually they
wouldn't it would stiffen up so when
people were saying Cove is not real and
you know it was you know I knew the
treatment and I knew what was going on
and we've never had a stretch where
everybody needed pressure ventilation
right it was like what is going on with
this and that's what happened with
everybody we just couldn't ventilate
them sure diabetes played a factor sure
congestive heart failure played a factor
you know we didn't get many young
healthy people that died of covid yeah
but the the the rate and the amount was
overwhelming so I knew it was real and
it was scared yeah you got to understand
that
again I told you I had a candle off in a
badge as as Gear Well the police
departments and and even us we didn't
have much PPE at the time so I would be
on scene and you know uh pronouncing
someone with covid and I'm looking
around and the cops had homemade masks
you know yeah talking Tampa I mean maxi
pads and panties stretch over their ears
to block their Airway some guy's wearing
yeah like a Halloween costume yeah and I
you know I can remember one time where
on a scene and you know when you find a
large amount of money on a scene and
you're in that moment and you you open a
duffel bag and there's you know eighty
thousand dollars you it's just human
nature to do you know wow you stare at
it a minute not that you would take it
it's just interesting but you deserve
ten percent of this yeah
that's my tip that's that tariff bruh
but so one time you know we this guy was
he came in he worked in a offshore or
something and you know when we trying to
figure out why this 50 year old guy or
40 year old guy is dead opened his bag
and uh you know sometimes we'll find
drugs and other things but in his bag he
had some true 3M uh masks and I can
remember that and we were all just
salivating over like wow you know he'd
probably taken him from offshore but we
didn't even have wow that protective
gear and just to see him with a case of
those it would be like man I would love
a box of those right about now it was
scary yeah you know because we didn't
know what covet was and what it could
cause and family and children and
getting home I'd sit outside every night
and
watch TV and stay away from my family
because we were so exposed to that you
know
um vaccinations that's a whole nother
story but you know the I took one
because I was just seeing too many
deaths
um yeah I can imagine from your
perspective that had to be crazy yeah it
was like here's this new thing we don't
know what's going on a lot of people are
saying that it doesn't exist a lot of
people are saying that it's
um you know that it's man-made a lot of
people are saying these things that like
whatever methods we're using to uh treat
people or what's killing them you know
um
yeah there were people on social media
friends of ours that were going out of
their way to tell people that it was all
a bunch of then you know don't
wear a mask and don't do this and and
here I'm sitting with compositions in
every part of the house with deaths and
I'm thinking why are you going out your
way to tell people this isn't real or
it's a political hoax or what you know
just it was tough yeah
come follow me around and let me show
you how real this is you know it was It
was a people had their own opinions
about it so I I never got involved into
the you know who says here yeah I just
well I think at first I didn't know if
it was real I don't know I've always
been super untrustworthy of a lot of
stuff so but
um but also I never got different
people's experiences are different too
some people never got sick so they never
had any you know and then they never
knew anybody that got sick right so then
to some people it's like what is even
going on you know and that's their
reality you know
um so and you can't blame them right
yeah that's what I'm saying you can't
blame some people you can't blame their
reality I think some because that's
their truth how could they know anything
else right but then I think there was a
lot of uncertainty
um and also just people not trusting the
news anymore there used to be a time
where you trusted the news right
absolutely you felt like it was genuine
it at least had some semblance of the
best interest for Humanity and that was
kind of eroding right then right so I
think at that point when both those
things happen at the same time you know
a lot of conspiracy theories are or
sometimes what can later be seen as
truthful you know a lot of stuff that
was conspiracy then now people are
saying it was correct so it's just you
know a lot of that's kind of um
absolutely
were alternate ways to treat yourself
Joe Rogan was you know right about some
of the medications and therapies he
encouraged as well as uh talking about
obese versus healthy people and all that
was spot on yeah you know
um but it was tough to witness and see
and pronounce a lot of friends and I
knew it was real right especially right
where you are I mean you standing right
there at the Finish Line dude absolutely
do you ever feel like you were like
when people died does it feel like
they're going somewhere else do you feel
like do you think like all right this
person's going to heaven or this
person's going to hell or do you ever
have any little thoughts like that or
um yeah I have opinions you know on some
people that I that I might know but me
too I don't say nothing but me too yeah
um no I'm not you know
you know they're in a better place
um I often think you know God's gonna be
hard to to lose my father or or my wife
um and then I I witnessed my
father-in-law die of cancer and he was
struggling there at the end and uh to
know that he was no longer struggling
and when he finally passed there was a
there was a peace you know so I think
you can I can accept that in some
regards later in life because you know
you see you see the the the really bad
deaths and you see people that struggle
and sometimes it's you know I'm glad
they were God took them uh you know from
away from this pain and suffering so
yeah
yeah do you feel like um do you ever
feel like people are go like do you get
any insight I guess into just being
around death so much right because a lot
of us aren't around it right we can't
even go you know we people want to find
a dead body they can't you know people
are but you get to be around it kind of
do you ever feel like
that people are like do you ever get any
insight if people are leaving to a
better place or if they're like do you
feel anything like that do you think you
get any more insight than just the
regular person sitting around wondering
what the afterlife is like or anything
no
um but in those instances I'm I'm so
overwhelmed with evidence and and
looking at things that I'm not really
again when I see someone that was
suffering or maybe they're 80 pounds and
they were once 200 pounds I'm I'm you
know somewhat relieved that they're gone
but uh as far as for
the afterlife I you know I know in my
faith that you know they're they're
going to a better place
so
um
but I have you know back to your
question I've you know I guess I've
joked and said well this guy's going
straight to hell yeah you know
sometimes you gotta but yeah he's going
straight down yeah but again that's just
personal joking stuff like that yeah
um you know um
so crystal meth came and that drug is is
really rough on people it turns people
into monsters really really does these
people I mean they just turn into demons
they do things that most normal people
wouldn't do but it's interesting when I
have someone that abuses meth and I go
into their home
because these people are up all night
fidgeting they can't sit still
electrical yeah yeah they do electrical
sometimes they want to I've had people
take electrical wires and try to create
things and they shock themselves
um but what's interesting sometimes is
the things they make like drone
deflectors I went into a house once and
they had all these weird things hanging
and I actually went home and built one
just as a memorabilia but
um you'll take they'll take a electrical
cord or rope and then they'll they'll
sew or wrap a barbecue spatula on the
end of it it makes no sense but they
would put them in all the corners of
their houses and I'd ask families like
hey what's that what's going on with all
this and dream catcher to Arby's yeah
yeah and it's like hey that's drone
that's that that's what he said
deflected the drones you know so it's
kind of kind of cool like oh man you
know the paranoia would set in and
it's interesting you know it's sad and
it's terrible and and all of the above
but it was interesting to see some of
that it is some of the creativity
there's a lot of like odd creativity in
myth you can tell when you go into a
house when there's calculators taken
apart and just things that you know are
disassembled everywhere you know that
okay this person was was on some type of
amphetamine
you ever had to go
um you ever found somebody hiding
somewhere real neat like or somebody
died during hide and go seek or
something uh yeah well you know there
was a guy under a house once you know
and uh you know no clothes on
I wouldn't like that part yeah naked
under a house
eating popsicles oh yeah yeah I mean
that you know that's uh that's different
yeah yeah that's a different way to do
it PCP you know oh yeah makes you makes
you a bit crazy uh
but you know truck drivers we get truck
driver deaths a lot they're from out of
state why why do you get truck driver to
death a lot well not a lot but we get
them we have truck stops and a lot of
times they'll pull over and look truck
drivers aren't healthy I mean they're
big guys because they drive all day long
yeah and uh you know sometimes I'll I'll
get called out and I'll be in somebody's
truck I've never been in a truck
driver's truck before until I started
doing this and I'm looking at how they
live and
um
you know they they notify their parents
by their family by phone and so the you
know maybe the wife's flying in to get
his personal belongings and the truck's
full of condoms and it's like oh man I
don't want this wife coming into his
truck so you know hey can we throw this
stuff out you know before the wife gets
there yeah give him up give him a little
disrespective we'll do I don't want the
Family's last thoughts to yeah you know
so there are there are uh different
cases and different positions that we're
in for sure
um it's it's just it's an interesting
job and you know
um I'm very sympathetic and
compassionate when I'm you know we we
all get faster as we work we get faster
at things we do you know we learn how to
do them faster and um every once in a
while I have to stop and remind myself
to slow down and to make eye contact
with that family and and to be really
compassionate you know yeah
um yeah that's the nature of everything
I think once you get in the flow of
something too much you know yeah you do
it too fast yeah and you don't stop to
you know maybe spend that extra time
with them to reassure them that you know
that their family's taken care of so
yeah
things like that yeah I mean it's easy
to even joke about you know from being
removed from it you know it's like it's
easy sometimes to try and make levity of
some of the situation you know
um
what are there things you that you guys
have done like in the moment or things
ever that happened you try to keep some
levity in the situation because yeah the
only opposite to such a dark moment is
some levity you know
we'll tease the officers
joke around with the officers on scene
not so much the person playing there but
um you try to pick up their spirits
you know um
in all sorts of ways you know sometimes
you can ask them to to hold something
and they think they're actually doing
something that needs to be done and
they're just holding a needle and you
know an hour later they're still
standing there holding that needle and
it's like you can let that go now you
know
um but yeah we you know you you have to
have a a bit of humor otherwise it'll
eat you up yeah you know you know what's
sad is uh for folks like us uh you know
we're underfunded we we use our own
cores and you know the things we do wow
um we don't have protective gear so when
I go out we recently just got some but
when I go out to say a homicide which is
we're seeing so many of those now yeah
um African-American kids are done by gun
violence and Caucasian kids are dying
from drug overdoses and it's
overwhelming but when we get called out
to a homicide a shooting you know and in
one of the cities close to us they're
rated the number one uh
dangerous place to live in Louisiana per
capita for the homicides and in within
my parish and so it might be three
o'clock in the morning and I go out to a
shooting
and I'm walking up to that scene well by
the time I get there again last
responder right so I get there by the
time I get there everybody in the
neighborhood and family and friends are
all on scene so I'm parking three blocks
four blocks deep
and having to walk through a crowd of
people that I don't know that are upset
angry hi you name it yeah and I have to
go to find that body in the police
officers and it can get hairy you know
and I'm in Scrubs you know I'm not
I'm not dressed in a bulletproof vest or
anything I've been on scene where shots
were fired it was a block away but you
know when you're in scrubs and shots are
fired you know it's pretty tough yeah
um yeah because somebody's already dead
yeah I'm gonna start saying that hey so
you know yeah well there was a case in
North Louisiana where the guy had uh was
shot and the paramedics were working on
him a friend of mine was actually on on
this scene and so they're working on him
and a guy walks up and says hey man is
he going to make it and the paramedic
said yeah I think he's going to pull
through and the guy shoots him right
there boom boom boom puts three more
rounds in him you know so scene control
can be tough when there's you know two
officers and 300 people
um yeah just recently and and again my
condolences go out to this this officer
who was just killed in in another Parish
next door to us I mean great guy really
good guy and um there wasn't many people
there for scene control and one of my
friends was showed up as a marshal and
the whole crowd was telling him it's
about time when he all died you know and
and just saying things that you know you
all need to die and you know you have
guns but we have bigger guns when you're
by yourself
you know at 10 o'clock at night with 300
people
cussing at you I mean that's that's
that's hard that's hard for those
officers yeah they don't get paid enough
to no and and they don't they don't at
all they really don't nobody would and a
lot of these young officers haven't been
through health care and they see things
that I see we see them more frequently
but still those young officers that are
22 23 they're looking at things that
they've never seen before you know and
like you mean victims and stuff like
that yeah well every death that I see
you know decomposed bodies yeah you name
it children and babies and
it's uh it's tough for those guys and
I have a Partners in a company where we
do psychological evaluations for law
enforcement oh that's wonderful yeah so
we have a team of psychologists that
review they take them through different
tests and instruments and and determine
if they're suitable for law enforcement
and uh right now the only people that
are that are applying for law
enforcement are high risk and that's
what makes it tough for uh City police
you know you got to hire somebody who
was shoplifting two months ago right you
know so they're not getting a good batch
of officers right now and cops in
general have been put down
uh you know the whole defund the police
oh yeah all that stuff's ridiculous so
it's it's uh yeah and you have people
moving out of cities there's just so
much there's so much crime in a lot of
cities you know I was just in Memphis uh
the other day and it's beautiful great
city right gets really dangerous you
know there's a lot of like
there's a lot of shootings a lot of
black crime too you know unfortunately
like when I was growing up two of my
best friends my black friends got killed
by other young black men you know I I
think it's just a bummer some of that
happens because it makes it scary to
live in certain places very you know and
then it's like if you want to move away
from places like that people say oh well
it's like white flight or you're right
or it's a racial issue but it's like
it's just fear it's like you just want
to be safe it's you know it's I don't
know and this look there's all types of
violence but well it's sad to see a lot
of that a lot of these kids are uh 14
and 15 years old and they you know
trading video games and hey I'll buy
that game from you okay I'll meet you
and then hand on the video game up and
shoots them yeah so they're not it's not
all drug related deaths some of it's
over you know you called me out on
Facebook and they kill them I mean I
don't understand that they're they're
not scared to go to jail right or prison
and they and they do when they're eight
team they get let go uh to some degree
but it's just it's an overwhelming
amount of young healthy kids dying on
both sides I mean again the the drug
abuse is rampant and the homicides are
happening are rampant so if you're
noticing more in White Community it's
drug overdose yeah absolutely and in
black community it's more gun violence
absolutely it's
man it's scary to see
you know
the disregard for Life yeah you know and
The Accidental ODS and I can't stress
enough that you know the synthetic drugs
that are being sold in stores are
dangerous you know it throws these kids
into seizures but they're being sold in
stores absolutely you can go Oh you mean
like at the gas station
crack gas crack all that kind of
PlayStation heroin was Mitch yeah it's
called at all or you know and kids go
buy this and it you know that might not
kill them but they have seizures that
get that's what kills them is they'll
have a major seizure when they take this
stuff I can't believe we allow that
stuff to be sold then yeah it's um they
say watch Alabama for some reason
everything starts in Alabama with that
kind of stuff and then Alabama Outlaws
it but as soon as they outlaw it
something else is coming back yeah you
know so it's uh it's scary raising kids
you know
um even on social media you know you can
you can get on Instagram or or
any of the platforms and Order drugs
yeah and and you know while we're
sitting here I can order a pound of
cocaine and have it shipped to my house
and it'll be here in three days you know
and kids have access to that I'm going
home with y'all and you know what I'm
saying yeah what do you want no I don't
know I know you're right though if
there's vpns people can you can get like
Dr it's
the postal service is the biggest
distributor of illegal narcotics in the
U.S you know it's it's it's scary
raising kids with gun violence and you
know just all these different things
that can
yeah yeah it almost seems like it's just
becoming like another country that I
think that it seemed like when I was
growing up you know when I was a child
drugs didn't kill you back then no you
know nobody shot you
um it's different you know yeah but
they're still you know there's still
positive things that I can help people
with one area I did want to mention is
babies yeah my God child just had a baby
and yeah babies yeah I see you know we
work babies we have a not a large amount
but babies die newborn babies
[Music]
um
some of the things you can do is you
know when we raised our children they
all slept in the bed with us we put them
right there in bed with us and luckily
we never lost a kid but if you have a
baby I've never pronounced the baby in a
baby bed
or
um a pack and play one of those little
small cribs you know it what happens is
um parents will put babies in
um in the middle of a king-sized bed
because they're so small they can't even
roll yet and they put them in that bed
and they'll they'll basically suffocate
we all used to say it was SIDS but it's
truly positional asphyxia so that Airway
is like a straw and if that's straw
Kinks but as long as you're using baby
products you know like a baby bed I've
never pronounced the baby unless unless
of course they were using like an adult
blanket in a baby bed so there's things
you can do in that regard you know to
that's things I can teach people so not
have your baby in bed with you don't put
your babies inside with you don't put
them on the couch sleeping while you
wash dishes because they roll off
they'll roll off they'll get wedged or
the the pillow is so soft that they
can't adjust their uh head and neck you
know so there's things I can teach
people that you know how preventable
deaths and babies is one of them
something that I can you know share with
with with new parents and yeah you know
it's super important yeah so you know
there
bad can happen when you do
everything right you know so you just
got to be careful and every day is a
gift you know do you think it was a
reason you got into that line of work
then do you think there was like
something that like you had this like
you know this dark side that led you
into it it seems like you came a little
bit more through like the medical
profession
um or through the insurance like just
was it the what were you guys selling
you said uh What uh products were you
working with before you got into well I
was in respiratory you know so I but
I've always had a uh I've always leaned
towards Health Care I've always worked
in the trauma area of healthcare
um so you there's something fascinating
about it a little bit yeah I've always
just had it I was just born to do this
kind of stuff you know I don't I don't
do the coroner's office for money it's
not a you know I saved my best thing my
best friend's life and I look back on
that and you know it was a blessing to
have that yeah that ability Amen to be
able to just be there and be a part yeah
if you hadn't been there who knows yeah
that's a real gift you know but yeah I
don't know what what shifted me into it
um it's kind of like I was always uh
set up to do this kind of stuff yeah you
know and you can handle it absolutely
and to you uh your retired police
officer he was like man those guys can
eat yeah we can eat you know that
doesn't bother me I can eat a meatball
sub or boudin cracklins in an autopsy
break room damn you know when you're
hungry you hungry
I don't know I wouldn't have a French
dip though that seems a bit much yeah if
it's pretty good I like french dip I
would do that at home I think yeah now
we don't eat standing over a body you
gotta stand off to the side yeah yeah
yeah just a little break room yeah
yeah plus down in Southeast Louisiana
bruh or if you're down in Southwest a
lot of the bodies down there could be
caused by Dustin Poirier too dude yeah
that's right if you're down to Southwest
Louisiana right if you got a good ass
whooping I'm not saying he's a serial
killer but uh definitely know right
right I bet if you CH you know yeah you
know fighting I had we had a young guy
died he was punched once and it was a
hard enough hit and he collapsed and hit
the cement and that's really unfortunate
but again it doesn't take much
you know
life's pretty fragile does it seem like
that it really is it really is every day
is a gift man some of the things we get
frustrated with with our family and and
friends
um are not worth the frustration because
they may not be here tomorrow or you
won't be here tomorrow you know and I
learned that yeah have you learned that
has that had a big effect on you that's
really fascinating yeah you're like this
is not a big deal yeah it's really not
you know you could be pumping gas and a
tire flies off a car and takes you out
you know
um I've had you know
single trees fall on cores you know just
the most bizarre
things but when God's ready for you he's
going to take you God and so yeah it
makes you aware of your surroundings but
you can help people uh you can you know
back to the preventable deaths you can
tell people what not to do
and uh you know it helps you through
life you ever do you ever worry about
your own ego like I would be like Oh I'm
like you know
like I have some special gift or
something does that ever
no man I'm real laid back
um what you see is what you get I'm
caging you know yeah I just kind of Roll
With the Flow I'm not special you know I
don't get speeding tickets that's a plus
that's fair it's nice knowing the police
yeah
[Music]
I keep a blood vial with uh I don't even
know what I have in it maybe coffee I
keep it in my glove box in all our cars
so if I'm going to Houston and I get
pulled over ever since Ebola man cops
don't like body fluids oh yeah so if I
get pulled over you know I'll whip out
that biohazard bag with some coffee in
it now hey I'm transporting this to
whichever direction I'm going you know
I'm bringing this to Methodist oh it's
body fluid you can go you know they
don't even want to shake my hand on
saying oh man you know they give me a
little fist bump or an elbow yeah
sometimes my hands are dirty and
intentionally I'll say hey can I borrow
your ink pen and they're like no bruh
yeah you know gonna hold your flashlight
you know I need to look at this and they
like no bruh
so you know do your hands get dirty on
the scene yeah I mean but I'm wearing
gloves right so there was a case you
know I have to put my hands in it you
know the worst of the worst worst of the
worst and
um there was there was a pedestrian just
something I didn't talk about man
pedestrians are dying and what is
pedestrian pedestrians people walking oh
God man so you had mentioned you know
going out and maybe having a beer or two
well you go out and have a couple of
drinks one drink at a dinner meeting
then you eat dessert and have a cup of
coffee and you're driving back on that
dark two-lane road at 11 o'clock at
night there's going to be
pedestrians but there's going to be
somebody walking in black clothes on the
street and you're going to run over them
I mean it happens and as soon as you do
that they're drawing you blood but
pedestrians are dropping like flies and
we're so distracted right because people
on their phone yeah I mean look I'm I
text and drive I'll be the first one to
admit it and sometimes I'm driving I
hear that that rough sound when you when
you venture off the road you know and
I'm like oh you know oh yeah that's the
Lord's Braille right there
that's right and look man that that that
could have been somebody standing right
there yeah it happened it used to be
walk walk with traffic but now I tell
people man walk against traffic so you
can see who's coming because everybody's
distracted oh that's such a great Point
yeah that that's totally changed
absolutely walk towards traffic so you
know yeah you you have to be the one
who's alert now they're not alert
unfortunately people are walking towards
traffic looking at their phones so even
they swerve out you know bike riding man
we were raised on bike you know oh the
team Murray Mafia you know and
back we don't let our kids when they
were younger I don't let them ride bikes
in town anymore because people aren't
paying attention adults on bikes getting
mowed over you know it's it's adults on
bikes is weird also I think you don't
need to be wearing them tight pants
anyway in that helmet but if you do
decide to do that yeah do it in a track
yeah because man we've had friends that
have gotten hit on highways and they're
not dead but you know they've taken
really bad uh had really bad accidents
you know but so yeah we see I forgot
where I was going prior to that but we
we do see a lot of pedestrians now I
think it was talking about preventative
things you know with that word you know
like yeah things to look out for you
just want to cover everything too I know
that you wanted to you know just be able
to share a lot of information as to like
I think we've learned a lot about like
all the different areas your job kind of
encompasses you know the different types
of things that you can see that come in
um you know the different
responsibilities of the coroner's office
that we didn't know about
um and then it's your affiliation to it
you know that you're not some kind of
dark lord or anything yeah that you are
I don't have any Adams Family tats yeah
you know yeah you know you're just a man
that can handle it I'm a little
different you know I'm definitely not
right but uh you know uh
we have a we so we have a Willie Nelson
mannequin in my house he's a full-size
mannequin and people always like man
what's that you know my kids even when
they were they were scared of them but I
had a crazy Aunt who had mannequins as
company and she was living and you were
in Covington if not if I'm not mistaken
and when we moved her back she had all
these mannequins and I was a young kid
and every time we would go to her
retirement home they were in different
positions we're in different clothes and
that was her company she was really had
some psychics yeah so when we had kids
I'm like you know what I need to carry
that family tradition we need a
mannequin in here so uh we had one we
took it to on Arkansas vacation with us
and the the camp next to us just wasn't
quite sure about us yeah because I
pointed facing their cabin right
and then uh I found that Willie Nelson
mannequin in a place that a guy sold the
to me and it's just a lot of fun it's
different it's weird yeah it's cool uh
we took him to New Orleans in a
wheelchair and pushed him around but
most people didn't even notice him you
know yeah but I would set him somewhere
and just watch people walk by and say
excuse me you know so uh yeah we're
different people we you know but well
yeah if you play in a man if you're
taking mannequins running wheelchairs I
think that that is a I understand I
think it all makes perfect sense now but
yeah I think you got to have some fun
Louisiana's always been like that
absolutely people always having fun my
mother love Willie Nelson
um I'm trying to think we grew up near a
prosthetic place that was making process
over at this joint and they'd throw a
lot of them out the ones that didn't
come out good oh wow so we're always
beating the out of each other with
legs yeah just ambidextrous legs
and all kind of that's awesome yeah
it wasn't really legit you know right so
kind of adjust your perspective on
things absolutely you know Louisiana's
always had a decent you know I think
it's it's not a place where there's a
lot going on but you know there's not a
lot of big businesses I don't think
there's any Fortune 500 companies in
Louisiana except maybe Entergy and I
feel like they probably I think that
they moved out but so it's a lot it's
just about people and having fun yeah
that's Louisiana have a good time yeah
it really is man and I think you got to
make the best time you can uh no matter
what you're doing and you guys are in
you guys police officers it's just a
position where you know it's not very
rewarding and you catch a lot of people
on their worst day absolutely the worst
days yeah nobody calls like hey Corner
yeah having a great time right right
like I said I can't go have a cup of
coffee with a friend without them
thinking that that you know they did bad
news small town you know yeah dude
you're almost like that plink like that
uh like a uh like a roulette that ball
you know yeah you just drive around the
neighborhood and then you stop wherever
you want especially during covid you
know
somebody's dead I just stayed home I
mean it was like Monty Python you know
bring out your dad you know but I'm not
dead yet that's what it was that you
know it uh yeah no it's an interesting
it's an interesting field for sure well
look man I I just yeah well I appreciate
you coming in man I appreciate you
spending time and yeah um yeah it's
really nice of you dude this has been
cool to learn about you know I think we
like to just learn uh from different
occupations and stuff and so now I know
a lot more about what a corner does yeah
it's um it's always interesting and
somebody has to do it and uh you know we
try to we try to get get the job done as
compassionately and as we can yeah you
know so really appreciate you having me
on yeah man you're the guy that does it
man Toby savoir that's right thank you
bro Louisiana I appreciate it yeah dude
I love to come down there bro and catch
a body y'all do ride-alongs or not now
we can yeah you have to throw on some
scrubs or a lab jacket but yeah we'll
we'll bring you I'll do that yeah it'd
be cool man yeah I would love to come
down we could get Discovery to do you
know a rural rural coroner's office yeah
watch me check the fridge and call out
groceries I like that bro
yeah that'd be a cool game so you call
out the groceries then we guess who's
dead or whatever yeah yeah or why yeah
exactly well it all pretty much be heart
disease but yeah yeah that's true
the number one killer man that's right
things we things we live on yeah Toby I
appreciate you so much for your time
thank you guys for coming out it's been
a it's been a great opportunity to come
out here and talk and I hope this
podcast even saves a few lives people
may hear what not to do you know or or
be more aware of their surroundings and
that's pretty righteous I was thinking
about that especially during the
holidays especially about times when
you're like well is it worth it to take
this road for a couple minutes faster to
get home what's the really the safest
possibility for myself or my family
because yeah ever there's a lot of
dangerous turns out there these days and
it's up to the individual really in the
end you know to try and put themselves
in a best situation especially in our
country or our laws and stuff like that
aren't even going to do that anymore for
us right
absolutely Toby Savoy thank you so much
brother thank you man I appreciate it
you bet
[Music]
but it's gonna take